(lips smacking)
- I hate when you do that.
- Why?
- It sounds disgusting.
(lips smacking)
- It's the sound of my thighs when I run.
- Is this how girls feel when
they hear the word moist?
- No.
(lips smacking)
- Oh God.
Oh God. It makes me feel dirty. Stop it.
(relaxed music)
- Welcome to this episode
of the Trash Tastes podcast,
where we talk about not anime,
but we might talk about
anime today actually so.
- Who knows, who knows, if,
are we feeling spicy today?
- We'll never tell.
(hosts laughing)
- I might bring up anime
and then immediately
tangent from who knows?
- Who knows? Not even
we do, most of the time.
What are we going to talk about?
- Right.
- This is like a themed episode.
- I did, I did think what I
was going to talk about today
because I was the host I was like,
"Connor. You have to think about
"what we're going to talk about."
- Go on then.
What, what do you want to talk about?
- You know, I will talk about.
- Do you want to introduce us,
by the way? We're the boys.
- No, I'm not introducing you.
They know who you are by now.
We're on episode 49.
They should know who you are, nearly 50.
But yeah no, so a few weeks ago
I watched the JoJo event.
- Of course you did.
- Of course I did, where
part six was announced,
which was great.
- Yes.
- Which is why everyone watched
it because they were like,
"Will part six get announced? Who knows?"
- But imagine if they
didn't announce part six
after all that.
- I think it would have been very sad.
I should fully explain
if you're not a JoJo fan,
don't worry, do need to explain.
Basically there's a
whole event around JoJo.
They didn't say
they were going to announce
a new anime adaptation,
but everyone was like,
"They said, it's the biggest
event in JoJo history."
So I think they're going to announce it.
Otherwise, I don't think
this is the biggest event.
- Do they normally do JoJo events,
just randomly out of the blue?
- I've, I never heard of one.
- This has been planned
for a very long time.
apparently actually.
A year ago. I think actually.
- Have they done one before this?
- I feel like they have, but then, then,
but then if you go to
YouTube and you type in
JoJo live on TV,
they just probably constantly
get the voice actors to do
kind of what they did in this event.
So I guess I'll walk you
guys through the event,
basically what happened.
- Yeah, 'cause I didn't get to watch it.
- I didn't get to watch it
either. I just saw the reaction.
- So, yeah. The reactions
we'll get into that.
- Okay.
- It was fun.
First of all, the event, we
weren't really told anything.
So you didn't know anything
that was happening.
All we knew is that
there was a $40 price tag
(Connor exhales)
to watch the live stream.
- Oh, it was pay-per-view.
- Pay-per-view. Yeah.
- Yeah, 40 bucks.
- Jesus.
- Wow.
- Which is a, little steep.
- Eat your heart out Jake Paul.
- And we were, yeah right?
YouTube boxing match JoJo event please.
But it was yeah,
so it was a pay-per-view and
we weren't told anything before
we were just told it's going to be
the biggest event in
JoJo history add an echo,
add a reverb to that.
- As if they don't say
that for every event.
- You know how they are in Japan.
I feel like they hype things
out way beyond belief.
- Yeah of course.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Again, we weren't told anything.
So essentially what happened
was is that they did like
kind of like a game show kind of thing
in the start with some
of the voice actors.
So every main character Joseph.
If you don't know JoJo,
don't really worry about it.
It's not important.
Basically the voice
actors, they were like,
they quizzed them about the show.
It's kind of like meh game show.
- It's basic Japanese
TV variety kinda thing.
- Yeah yeah. It was
basically like Family Feud
but with the JoJo characters
which actually sounds
really good actually.
I can make that. I want to watch that.
- How well did you do in the quiz?
- Well I did, I did. We'll
get into this actually
- Okay. Okay. Okay.
- And then, you know, it was like cool.
And the voice actors performed
some of their scenes,
which was like the best part, right?
You know, they would do,
they would all do the most dramatic scene
from their respective part of the show,
which is really good.
Yeah. And then in the
end they announced it
and it went over the time.
It was supposed to be a two hour event
and my God did they talk a lot.
They very much, there wasn't
like a, like fast, it was like,
let's just talk about the
show. Talk about the scenes.
How did the scenes make
you feel? Tell us about it.
And yeah it was fine. It was fine.
But there's a few things that were
noteworthy about the event.
First of all,
is that the subtitles were
unusable, unreadable. Awful.
- Why is that?
- So in this, I said
this was a live event.
- Yeah.
- But a live event that was pre-broadcast.
- Like pre-recorded.
- Yeah. It was all, yeah
not broadcast. Sorry.
Pre-recorded totally, it was.
I'm not sure if it was
intentionally going to be
- So it's a live playback in a word.
- It's a live re, replaying.
- They basically just made
a YouTube premiere. Right?
I mean that's basically it right?
- It was edited like a
live Japanese TV show.
Like it was very minimal,
I guess, minimal in terms of
Japanese editing and stuff on screen.
- Bro, next time we do a
Trash Taste special with that.
We've got to make that
pay-per-view now man.
- We do. We should do
pay. What do we do man?
We're fucking dumb.
Just giving it for free,
what?
- What?
- And it's self-funded?
- Oh my God. We're
fucking, we're schmucks.
- Losing out on our money.
- So yeah it was, it was, it was $40.
Which, you know for a live event
it's a bit
- A bit hefty.
- I mean you can buy
a whole season of JoJo
on DVD for that or something, right?
- You could buy four episodes
of a JoJo on Blu-ray for that.
And don't get me wrong.
The event was very good.
It was very well-made
but it was just tragic
because you know,
how many events charge
$40 for you to watch them?
- Not a lot. Well I mean,
maybe like a concert of
like a mid ranged artists
is like $40, right? But.
- Online though?
- Yeah, not online. Like.
- Like a, I feel like boxing
events are the only thing.
- I feel like boxing ones
are the only ones that
maybe wrestling? Although,
- Right, true.
- I'm not like a, I don't watch wrestling,
but those are the ones I
think of when it's like,
- Yeah usually it's like, you know,
if you're paying 40 bucks,
you have to it's, it's an
in-person experience. Right?
Most of the time I would like to think.
- But with boxing as well,
they do it online as well.
And it's always like a fucking 80 bucks.
- Oh yeah.
- I mean, I feel like with boxing,
it's different to a lot of
sporting, other sporting events
because people like you're
building up months and months,
to this one moment.
Whereas other things like
football or basketball
there's like constant matches
throughout a season. Right?
But with boxing you have one event
that people build up
months to. And that's it.
So I can, I can understand
the pay-per-view price
or that model kind of
in that kind of sense.
- Boxing fans are hardcore as well.
- This is where I think like,
do I not understand the
Japanese market enough?
'Cause I'm like, is this like
the same level as of like a
international boxing event in
Japan, like this JoJo event?
Is it like the same level of like,
everyone, everyone's
stopping what they're doing.
- Well you know JoJo fans are.
- Yeah. But I wonder, I wonder.
if this is like, is this
the price is this high because
they're banking on JoJo fans
being as dedicated as they are,
which they are.
Or is it that they think
it's that big of an event
in general in Japan?
I don't know.
- I mean, I feel like
I'm not used to Japanese
business model period
because I feel like it's the only country
that can sell Blu-rays for
like hundreds of dollars
for like four episodes sometimes.
- Yeah, it's true.
- For a special edition and
people here will still buy it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. And watching
this live event was fun.
'Cause the live tweets were
quite, quite interesting.
People were not very happy.
- On the English side.
- It was really, yeah.
It was really, yeah, on the English side.
- It was really interesting seeing how
all the negativity got wiped away
the moment that like
part six was announced
and everyone was like,
"Guys, guys. It's worth it.
"It was, the event was worth it."
- Two hours of shit songs. I sleep.
- So yeah essentially
right. The, again, it was,
it was pre-recorded so this
could have been subtitled
like properly. It's not, you know,
you can get budget subtitles
and translations done
for this kind of length.
Like, you know, we get
subtitles done for the podcast
I think, to get the podcast captioned
it's like $150 an episode.
But if you wanted to translate it,
I think it would be into Japanese
for like an episode like this,
which I think is around
the same length is like
maybe like 800 bucks.
So it's not, in terms of a big business,
800 bucks for that kind of thing
for like low-end translating.
Probably not that much.
But instead they decided
for some reason to do
auto-generated subtitles.
- It's never a good sign.
- There was like, there was like,
people were just posting
screenshots of the subtitles.
It was like, "I'm going to
kill a kid or something."
was one of them
or something like really
funny out of context.
Like it was just really, really bad
to the point where it was like,
this is unwatchable if you
don't know any Japanese,
it's like the subtitles are
so bad. And it was just like,
I just wondered why, like,
this is such a good event.
Like you have, if you're a JoJo fan,
this event was amazing.
Like this is the kind of stuff
that if it was on YouTube,
it has like 5 million views guaranteed.
- I'm wondering like,
do you think they even
thought about the international
audience or were they
just really
- No of course not.
- marketing towards the Japanese audience?
- I don't think they were.
- Cause you like, even me living in Japan.
I only heard about it like the day before.
And that's because you
fucking posted about it.
Like I did not know, like this
wasn't talked about at all
on my timeline, at least.
So I didn't know about it
until just as it was happening.
- Yeah.
- If this was an event right? Where they,
it was only really able,
you're only able to pay in yen.
You were only able to buy
from a Japanese website.
I would. I would be like,
that's a fair argument.
You know, you went on
the Japanese website,
you went out of your way
to pay in the currency and.
- You're expected to listen
to it in Japanese. Yeah.
- You knew what you were getting into.
For some super fans, if they
don't understand a word,
that's fine.
But for me it was like, all right.
So the premiering, the
sharing like, Singapore,
US specifically, they
have a website in English,
they're charging you in dollars
and they're telling you
that going to be subtitled.
Think it's kind of fucked up.
- Yeah.
- Like again,
the event was great.
And it's just so sad that they kind of,
I feel like they mislead the people a bit.
- Oh yeah, well absolutely.
I mean, when have automated
subtitles ever worked?
- They barely work for captioning.
The language that they're doing.
- They barely work for our own language
when we upload it on YouTube, right?
There's auto-subtitles.
- Like what were they thinking?
It's been known to be one
of the hardest languages
to translate into English.
- Completely different grammatically.
- I think in terms of
a cost per like, like
per minute of translating
Japanese to English is
one of the most expensive.
- I'm not surprised by that.
- Because it's the hardest.
And then there's not,
there's not many people that can do it.
- It's grammatically
completely different as well.
- Right so then who decided
that this should be like,
this is a great idea and we're
going to charge $40 for this.
- I mean, I, I would
think for a $40 price,
you would get like more
professional subtitles.
- 100% percent.
- Like, I, cause I guess
this is the first I'm hearing about this.
But like when I hear live
events, I think, you know, you,
you understand there's some
leeway in an actual live event
where it's happening right as it's airing.
But if it was pre-recorded
then yeah I mean you could've
dumped the subtitles.
- Yeah. there was
nothing about this show
that needed to be live.
There is no aspect of it that
required a live audience.
- Yeah. If it's prerecorded
then like it's not like,
it's not like the host can
interact with the chat or
anything like that, right?
- So you're telling me you paid $40
just to see a part six announcement.
- Yeah.
(hosts laughing)
And I'd do it again Garnt.
- JoJo fans.
- JoJo
- JoJo fans in a nutshell.
- Pay for something I would have gotten
like five minutes later
anyway but, you know?
I don't know. I, you know,
I sat down and I was like,
"This isn't worth the $40".
Just the subtitles, the subtitles
it's just, it's like, you
know, at what point is it like,
do I need a refund? You know what I mean?
Like how bad do the subtitles
have to be where it's like,
I can't understand
anything that's being said.
- Well, I mean, I think that's
worthy of a refund, right?
Like you, you paid for
something that you didn't even
really understand.
And they didn't even
like give you the chance
to try and understand.
- It's really unfortunate as well
because people were like
dogging on them on Twitter.
And then the JoJo anime account
tweeted out, being like,
"Hey guys",
because there was a lot of
people streaming it on Twitch
and they were like,
"Guys, please don't pirate it there".
And then there was one, this is like,
I feel like as a company, you
should never ever say this.
You should never ever say the words,
"There is no excuse to
pirate" because I guarantee
within 10 seconds,
there's going to be 10 people
with 10 semi-decent reasons
why they pirated it. So for example,
and this is terrible.
So the show was only
available in the US, Singapore
and I think a few other Asian countries.
No Europe, no Europe at all.
Right? No, none of the other
American countries, nothing.
- Not even, not even Canada.
- Not even Canada.
So they were like, in
this tweet, they said,
"There is no excuse to pirate this thing".
And then in brackets they said,
"Sorry for the territory limitations".
And I'm thinking like,
"What is? What?"
- Oh no.
- So what is it? What is a
European fan supposed to do?
- Every European just unanimously is like,
- As a European, what am I supposed to do?
Tell me what I'm supposed to do.
- Just be born better.
- Just be born in a
better country. Obviously.
- Obviously, come on.
- Obviously I'm not, I'm
not promoting piracy,
but there is a way as a company
where that you can word
things or go about it.
- Just fly to Asia.
So you can watch it from
Asia during a pandemic.
- Just live in Japan. It's easy.
- You like anime. Just live in Japan.
- It's just, it's so
frustrating. Cause it feels like,
- I mean, it feels like this.
- You get shafted.
- Yeah. I mean, I feel like companies
should already have a understanding
that like territory limitations.
I like, I, in my opinion,
the biggest reason why people pirate.
- Absolutely.
- It's, it's been like this since
fucking the internet
was invented basically.
- Yeah. Like lost media.
I firmly believe, you know,
you should be able to,
if it's abandonware, or,
or completely lost and there's
no, you know, honestly,
I think that's okay to pirate.
I, I don't why would that not be okay?
No one has a stake in this anymore.
- Yeah. Like.
- It's literally history.
- Like isn't like PlayStation or Sony
shutting down the PS3, PSP
and PS Vita stores now?
So like, you know, even
though, even though like I,
you know, I, cause I own, I own a PS Vita.
And when I heard that I was like,
"Shit. What if there's a game
that I want on the PS Vita,
"I don't know what it is now",
but like, I'm not going
to be able to obtain it.
It's just lost media now.
And if you're not going to
make it readily available,
then someone's going to
archive this, you know?
And I, it's, it's,
it's a, it's a gray area,
but I feel like there is, you know, there,
there is a reason why
people do want to pirate
and do want to like archive this stuff.
You know I mean.
- There's definitely a, like,
it's not a matter of like,
"Oh, there's no excuse to pirate"
when it's like,
"No, there really is an excuse to pirate"
because it's literally the only way
I'll ever be able to
get a hand on it. Right?
- I mean, it's like, if you,
you would get someone who gets
into your product who never
would have been able to,
and never would have
had a chance to. Right?
And again with this
live stream, it's like,
why is this live stream
only in some countries?
Like, is it because
they're perhaps showing
scenes from the anime?
Is it probably a license?
Ah, probably is actually.
- It's probably a licensing
thing, but still it's like.
- It's a live stream, you know?
I mean, it's not like you
can't get it in every country.
- I mean, I mean,
I feel like that kind of
mentality just hasn't adapted to
just how the internet works
and just how the community
works now in 2021
or even fucking 2010.
- [Connor] 'Cause all the laws
are just completely outdated
and copyright law is just fucked.
- All laws are completely outdated because
they are all laws that are made for like
television broadcasts and
stuff like that, right?
- Especially in Japan.
- Yeah. Especially in Japan.
It just wasn't designed.
- I mean, we don't even
have fair use laws here,
which is ridiculous.
- Well, I mean, it's.
I feel like at least in the
US there is a mentality of,
okay, well
technically, you know,
live streaming a game and not
paying the, the, you know,
for a license to do that.
It's technically, you
know, legally speaking,
you're not allowed to do that.
But all the US companies
just kind of agreed,
it's beneficial, let them do it.
But I feel like that kinda
thing doesn't really happen.
There's not a,
there's not really a
thing of it's beneficial,
so let them do it.
You know, it's just another, you know,
it's like when you get events like this,
you're just reminded that, you know,
you're another one of those anime fans
being a westerner that yeah.
They don't care about you.
- I mean, I mean, I feel
like the mentality is slowly.
I mean, it took this long for it to change
with like Western companies
so God knows how long it's going to change
with Japanese companies.
- It is changing at a fucking
snail's pace, that's for sure.
- I mean, I like, I would say
at least Japanese companies
know that we exist now.
That's, that's, that's the
biggest difference, right?
Because imagine like five
years ago where they had
a American or they had like
an English site to promote
a Japanese live stream.
You know we, we are
taking very small steps.
- We've gone from snail
mail to dial up email.
- Yeah.
- It's been it's,
it's interesting because
it's almost similar to how
Japanese games are brought
over here. Right, like.
Here? I'm in Japan.
- To the west.
- Yeah Japanese games
were brought to the west,
but I feel like the,
the whole way the gaming
industry has gone. It's like,
it's like decades ahead
of where the anime is at.
And I wonder if that's because
they kind of grew at the same time,
like the culture of gaming
in America was its own thing.
And the culture of gaming
in Japan was its own thing.
And they kind of grew together
benefiting each other,
like they send games to each other.
And I wonder if that's,
if that's the reason why that
industry went so fast and why
sometimes people can't even
tell if a game is from Japan.
- Yeah. I think it's
also because like, yeah,
like American games now,
like now they're making games
in America and in Europe.
Whereas like,
I feel the anime industry
won't do that until we get
dedicated people who are
making it in America,
making it in Europe.
- 'Cause. I, I guess when maybe
when the Japanese businessman in like the
eighties or nineties
were making video games,
they were like,
"Oh yeah, there's tons of
gaming in the US. Let's go
"Send our products over there".
Whereas it's like,
"Oh, there's no anime there. Let's not,
"Let's not bother doing anything".
- I would also say that
from my perspective,
I feel like the anime
industry has always been like,
in my opinion like,
kind of like 10 years or so
behind the gaming industry.
- I feel like 20 sometimes now.
- 10 to 20 years in terms
of the popularity and how,
you know, how, how big the industry is.
- Right, right.
- Because I like, gaming
right now is probably the most
mainstream medium, entertainment medium
there is now, right?
- Gamers? Sorry.
- I mean, I mean.
- Rise up.
- Gaming makes more
than movies now, right?
- Yeah.
- So gaming right now.
- Well 'cause you can't
put microtransactions
in a fucking movie.
(Garnt laughs)
- That's true. That's true.
- You can't roll for your gacha
in the middle of "Parasite",
you know what I mean?
- Would you like to watch
the rest of this movie?
$5 please.
- But like, I would say
like within our lifetime,
we've seen gaming. We've
seen gamers rise up
(hosts laughing)
to become, the most biggest
entertainment medium in
the world now, right?
- When are weebs gonna rise up man?
- It used to be used to be movies.
Now do I think anime is going
to become as big as gaming?
No, but I would say that anime right now
is also rising up. Weebs rise up.
- It's on its way. It's on its way.
- It's on its way. It's
getting more popular.
- But then isn't it weird though,
that I feel like all the money
the weebs have is being
siphoned off in anime games.
- Yeah. That is true.
- I bet
- Anime games and Vtubers.
- I bet, I bet weebs spend
way more on anime games
than they do on anime merch and anime.
- Oh, 100%.
- 100%
- So all the weeb stuff.
All the weeb money,
there're just going in the fucking games.
- It's going to the gaming industry.
(hosts laughing)
It all comes back to the
games. I mean, I feel like,
probably if, if, if you,
if you interviewed like the
average anime fan, like not,
not, not the average anime fan,
the average weeb I would say,
the average person in the weeb culture.
They probably spend
more money on like games
or like VTubers than they
do on an actual like anime.
- Like a figurine or a manga
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. No, absolutely. 100%.
- It's, it's weird how that,
that's just the way
weebs work, but that's,
that's what I felt.
That's what I feel weebs put
most of their money into.
Maybe like, maybe in 2020,
maybe it's because there haven't
been like anime conventions
or things, other things they can buy.
But I would say that
the more I watch anime,
the less I buy like figurines
and stuff like that, you know?
Did you, do you feel like, I mean,
you're a hardcore JoJo fan, right?
So you, you, you put a lot of
your money into JoJo merch.
- Yeah invest in JoJo stock.
- Yeah, but now, but now,
you look for like the most
exclusive stuff, right?
You don't just buy like
the cheap casual thing.
- No I don't, if the figure
is under like 50 bucks,
I'm like, "I'm not interested".
I'm like that's peasant
stuff, get that out of here.
'Cause those figures are also cheap.
And also when you realize
that you start collecting
a lot of figures,
the one thing that becomes
more valuable than the figures
is the room they take up.
- Yeah.
- So then you're like,
"All right now I have to decide
"which figures are worthy of the display".
- Yeah. So I'm like slowly
starting to do that too with like
exclusively paintings or
like limited merch items
and stuff like that.
- I'm sure that sounds so fucking uh.
- It sounds so fucking.
- I'm so wealthy.
- Yes, I'm an art collector.
- But it's like, you know,
when you do you, when you
do start collecting figures
and you start getting a lot you're like,
"You know this $5 Goku figure, you know,
I kinda can't argue,
it deserves the same spot as
his $200 hand sculpted Rem
fucking like DNA
engraved, you know, thing.
- Like not, not even figurines
though, but like every,
anytime I go to an anime
convention or stuff like that,
I'd much rather buy shit
from the Artist Alley
and things that independent
artists are doing. Because,
most of the time they make cooler stuff
than the official
figures most of the time.
Or the official
merchandise, it's just like,
I don't understand people
who go to anime conventions
and they buy buttons.
To me, buttons, buttons are
the stickers for me, right?
- Like the metallic
ones right? Right yeah.
- I hate buttons man.
- Japan is fucking obsessed with those.
- I know. I know.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Why?
- Whenever I go to like
a pop-up shop for like,
you, you hear, you hear
an announcement where,
oh, there's a pop-up shop
for like X anime series
or Y anime series.
And I remember the first
few times I thought,
"Wow, cool. They got
exclusive merch there".
And it's like, 90% of
them are just buttons.
And to me, like buttons
are the merch you buy
when you don't, when you can't commit
to buying an actual merchandise.
(hosts laughing)
That's what buttons are to me.
- It's when you have that
chump change in your pocket
and go, "I can pay for this yeah".
- Yeah it's like the
equivalent of, you know,
when you go abroad and you're like,
"Oh, I guess I gotta
buy a souvenir, right?"
You go to Paris and
you go and you go like,
"Ah, I guess I gotta buy like a
"fucking Eiffel Tower key ring."
- Yeah. It's literally the
equivalent of like, I was here.
It's like I was at that pop-up store,
here is physical proof that
I was at that pop-up store,
a 500 yen shitty like
can, like tin can thing.
- Yeah.
- But then they gatchafy it
so you can't even buy the one you want.
You have to buy like 500 fucking buttons
until you get the one you want.
- There are people though
that I see that have,
you know like.
- Oh, the whole bags.
- Their entire bag or their entire like,
denim jacket or whatever.
It's just like covered
in them. And they just,
they sound like a fucking festival.
- Why would you put a bunch
of barnacles on your clothes
as far as I'm concerned, right?
That's what, that's what it looks like.
It looks like it looks ugly.
(hosts laughing)
It's ugly, and I won't stand for it.
- Yeah. No, people like it
man, I don't know what to say.
- One thing, one thing
about the JoJo event though,
that I wish that
I wish that anime did have
more of these kinds of events.
'Cause I will say like one thing that
always makes me jealous as an anime fan
from watching, you know,
the gaming community,
is that having this live event where
they have like a load of things
announced at once, right?
Like I've always been.
- Oh you want an E3 of anime?
- I kind of do.
(Connor laughs)
- I would love the presentations.
- Like honestly.
- Check this out.
- Honestly, half the fun of
E3 is just feeling like it's,
it's just like what feeling
like you're part of a community
and just watching it and
just reacting to it, right?
'Cause like, 'cause like to me,
like the closest thing anime has
is like the Anime Awards, right?
But we don't really have any like, what?
(Connor laughing)
- Just the mental image right?
- Just the thought of just
of some guy coming up like,
"Guys I'm proud to announce,
"Incest the Anime".
"Me, me and the team at Incest Anime
"have worked really hard", like
- This time, this time in 8K.
- Most anime I do not want to know
the thought process as
to why this came to be.
And I do not want to,
- Do you want, do you want?
- I do not want some 50
year old man telling me
why he thinks this 12 year old girl
should fuck this 20 year old man,
I don't want that.
I don't want to see a
presentation of that.
That is the last thing I want. And I also.
(hosts laughing)
- We hear you. Guys, we hear you.
You guys want more sister-fucking right?
- Last time we heard that the plot
got in the way of the incest.
So we decided to just go to Bang Bros.
- We upgraded that.
- Guys, we hear you.
You want another isekai.
- I just imagined it like, check this out.
The fucking PornHub,
the fucking thing plays.
(Connor mimics PornHub's beat)
(hosts laughing)
Oh my gosh.
- But do you like care
about most of the games
that get announced,
- No.
- Like you know,
you wait for that one JoJo
part six announcement,
you wait for. I don't
know what, what else?
- I think that we should
get more live events
to announce anime just
for the hype factor.
Like it makes sense.
- No, no, no. That's what I miss. I want,
I like the hype factor
in that the gaming
community have, you know,
it's, I, I feel like it's,
it adds to this community
aspect and it adds to the fun.
- I mean, Japan kind of has that already.
- [Connor] Do they?
- Yeah on Niconico, they have
this event called SUZUKIMI,
which I did the English
version of at AX last time.
But yeah, it's,
it's literally like a live
event where they get a bunch of
like voice actors and hosts
to announce the next season of anime.
- Maybe they should subtitle this.
(hosts laughing)
Maybe you could subtitle it.
- Like imagine how hype it
would be when you like you hear
like a "Chainsaw Man" adaptation is
instead of seeing it on Twitter, right?
You have this event where you're like,
"Oh, it's fucking", you
know, it's the next.
- The teaser trailer. Right.
- Yeah yeah the teaser
trailer where you're like,
Oh, is this "Chainsaw Man"?
Is this like, "Jujutsu Kaisen"
before they just got
animated. You know like.
- Like they just play like
scenes of the anime like,
"YEAAH!"
- "YOOO!"
- There are some manga series
I know people are waiting for
like imagine like one day
"Vagabond" gets announced
or some shit like that.
I would, I'd lose my shit, you know,
I think it would be cool if
anime had this kind of event
where we just announced a
bunch of new anime getting,
getting adapted.
- Why, we should do that.
(hosts laughing)
Honestly, like we're saying this idea.
I'm just like, no one's going to do it.
- Anime companies reach out to us.
- Yeah please we'll do it.
- It's just feels hard
being an anime fan you know?
Fuck we just, we spend, we
spend a fuckton of money.
We get, we get beat down on, you know.
Fuck man, it's hard when
you're not Japanese.
- This episode is sponsored by Honey.
- [Joey] We all shop online
and we've all seen that promo code field
taunt us at the checkout.
But thanks to Honey,
manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past.
Honey is the free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies to the best ones
that finds to your cart.
Honey supports over 30,000 stores online.
They range from sites that
have taken gaming products to
popular fashion brands
and even food delivery.
Did you know where that boys?
- Damn.
- Here's how it works.
Imagine you're shopping on
one of your favorite sites.
When you reached the checkout,
the Honey button drops down
and all you have to do is click
Apply Coupons, wait a few seconds
as Honey searches for coupons
that it can find for that site.
And if Honey finds the working coupons,
you'll watch as the prices drop.
- AHHHHHH.
- The other day gentlemen, a third party
delivery service app was not working.
So I needed to go through
a pizza supplier directly
and I saved 10 bucks on a $45 meal.
- That's an expensive pizza, but I'm glad
you save the money.
- Welcome to Japan.
- Honey has found its over
17 million members over
two billion dollars in savings.
If you don't already have Honey,
you can literally be straight
up missing on free savings.
It's literally free and
installs in a few seconds.
- And by getting it,
you'll be doing yourself a solid
and supporting this podcast.
- I never recommend
something that I don't use.
- Get Honey for free at
www.joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's www.joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
Back to the episode.
- It's like people watching
award shows, right?
Because, okay, here's the thing.
Nobody actually watches
an award show to like,
see who wins or to like
congratulate the winners.
We watch it to get salty
and to feel like we're
part of a conversation.
- Like a sporting event?
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah it is kinda
like a sporting event for
like entertainment, right?
I mean, that's, that's why
people watch, you know,
the Anime Awards,
the Gaming Awards and also
like the Oscars as well,
which apparently just aired yesterday.
(Joey laughs)
Nobody watched.
- At the time of recording.
- I didn't know it aired
until the day after
I was like, "Dude the Oscars aired?"
No one said anything.
- I only knew about it because
I saw a tweet of some guy who like
put down a list of the past 10
years worth of like viewers.
And apparently it was like
the lowest in, I think ever.
- I think it had halved in one year,
but that's also because
we didn't really have any
big theatrical releases this year.
- I mean we really didn't
really have any movies in 2020.
- Most movies went to HBO
Max or Netflix or whatever.
And also I feel that I didn't
realize now until this year.
Oh my God, all those ads
that these movies pay for
and all the, like the
promotional tools and whatnot
really do work.
'Cause I don't know anything about movies
unless they're doing these
like promotional tours.
- Yeah. Yeah, same here.
- Like I haven't heard,
I haven't heard of like
a single really big movie
that came out in 2020, obviously because.
- I only know about the Snyder cut
because that was like a meme
because it was four hours long.
- The Snyder cut was probably the biggest
kind of movie.
- That was a re-release.
- I think the only movie
I watched last year,
not even in cinemas,
but like afterwards was "Tenet".
- Oh yeah I watched "Tenet" in theaters.
That's really good.
- I didn't even watch that.
- So fucking good.
- I know. I heard so many people saying,
"Yeah, it was great".
- It's the most Nolan
movie you can ever imagine.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah. It's very much.
- I'm okay with that.
- It's almost as if "South
Park" wrote a parody
of a Christopher Nolan
film and then they made it.
- Like, do you know what the
main character is called?
- Ah, tell me.
- He's called the Protagonist.
- No. Yeah. Yeah.
- I shit you not, the main character
is just called the Protagonist.
He doesn't have a name.
He's called the Protagonist,
like a fucking Nishio Ishin hole.
- Dude, the fucking,
even if the story is kind of dumb,
like the visuals in that
movie are so fucking cool.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah.
- It's so good. And also Robert
Patterson, I fucking love,
I think he's an amazing actor.
I will watch anything's he's in.
- Oh yeah, he's fucking great.
- 'Cause I feel like watching
"Tenet" and I was just like,
Nolan's obviously just
given up on the script.
He just has a lot of
cool ideas for visuals
and the visuals were fucking cool,
but I pay attention to the plot
and the character for a
second. And I'm just like,
"What the fuck is going
on right now?", you know?
- Watching it in the movies
was like so exhausting.
It was literally that
I was posing like this.
So it's backwards in time. Okay.
It's pretty good. It's pretty good.
It's fun. It was one of those movies
that I couldn't imagine watching at home.
I feel like the big screen helped.
- I watched it at home.
- Bro.
- It took me like, it took me,
it took me two times to
watch because the first time
I just got really, really
bored in the first half.
- What?
- In the first half. Right?
Because the first half is all plot. Right?
- They had us in the first half.
- 'Cause like, I was like,
I'm not following what's going on.
I really don't care about.
- I'm like, I sleep until
Robert Patterson comes on
and like, I'm paying attention.
All right, what's up?
He's so good. I love him in everything.
- He's a fantastic guy.
- He's so fucking good. Have
you watched "The Lighthouse"?
- Yeah. I've seen that.
- I love "The Lighthouse".
- What's "The Lighthouse"?
- It's a movie with him and
who's the guy played Jesus Christ?
Um fuck, what is his name? I,
- William DaFoe.
- Ryuk. Who can forget
his famous reel of Ryuk
in "Death Note" live-action.
- The famous four lines
he said in that movie.
- Yeah William DaFoe is
a fucking amazing actor
and they're both in it and
they're both going crazy.
It's fucking amazing. I won't
spoil it. Go and watch it.
It's kind of an artsy
film, but it's really good.
It's really, really good.
You should watch it.
How many films do you watch?
Not many. Maybe,
- You probably go to the cinemas though
the most out of all of us though, right?
- Yeah. But I don't care
what I watched at the movies.
I'm just like.
- How do you not care
about what you watch?
- It is a stimulus in my eyes.
- Well, we'll come back to the Oscars.
We'll talk about that. But yeah. Okay.
Because I enjoy just the
experience of the theater.
I like the, I like the popcorn.
I like the fact that I can,
so I can ignore my phone.
- So how often did you
watch films at home?
- Ohh. Never.
- Yeah, because you're mostly just like
a Netflix
- Netflix,
- Kinda guy. Because I'm like,
I'm the complete opposite.
I only go to the cinemas if I know
there's a banger film I need to watch.
If not I'm just like, I
just watch it at home.
- Yeah.
- Pre, pre-Rona.
I was going like maybe once a week,
maybe once every two weeks,
- [Joey] Damn.
- because it was just like,
there's always something on and
they would always do reruns.
So I, I watched in Japan,
I watched "The Shawshank Redemption".
- In cinemas?
- In cinemas.
Isn't that weird?
- Why don't we just
not watch that at home?
- I just, why not?
I never got to watch it at the big screen.
Let's go and have a look.
The best film of all time
according to IMDB.
Why would I not want to
experience it on the big screen?
- I mean it's a great
film. Don't get me wrong.
- It's a fantastic film.
- But you can also watch it.
- I also don't feel bad if
I want to go and get more,
you know, drinks and popcorn.
I've already seen it like
10 times. Yeah, you know.
- So what you're saying is
you just want the popcorn.
- I really, okay.
- You wanna eat popcorn in a big room.
- Can you not, can you
not eat popcorn at home?
- No, not really.
I legitimately don't go to the movies,
the theater now because
they don't sell popcorn in
the 'Rona. I don't want to go.
- Not because there's a
pandemic. Just no popcorn.
- Well they're not selling
that because of the pandemic.
But if they let's say the
pandemic was still on,
I would very much socially distance.
- You can sneak some fucking popcorn in.
- I don't want to bring my popcorn.
I want their popcorn.
- You want the overpriced
popcorn, fucking popcorn.
- Actually, it's reasonably
priced in Japan at least.
I do not want to go.
I'm sure there's someone
out there who agrees.
I do not want to go to the fucking cinema
if I'm not getting popcorn,
it's not it's I just don't want it.
- I don't think I've ever
bought popcorn in the cinemas.
- I'll literally, legitimately
go to a restaurant before,
I'll be full as fuck. I'll be
like gagging at how full I am.
And I'll be like, "One
large popcorn please."
- I don't know what's going on. Ooooh.
- I'll literally be dying. I do not care.
I have to get popcorn.
- What I don't understand, is some people
like some of, some of my
friends who, you know, we,
we go to the movies or
we'll go to the cinema
and it's at this awkward time
of like 1:00 or 1:30. You know?
- I'm getting popcorn.
- And it's just like,
do you eat lunch before?
Or do you not eat lunch before?
- [Connor] Before, before.
- And some people were just
like, the popcorn is my lunch.
I'm just like, how the
fuck is popcorn lunch?
- Popcorn is not anything.
I'm pretty sure you can't
even live off popcorn now.
- It's not, it's not a meal.
- No. Pretty sure it's negative calories.
Am I right? Right.
It feels like it.
- When you kind of just eating, air right?
- One time in Japan,
I spilled my popcorn over the floor and
I think that ruined
the whole movie for me.
I think that legitimately made my whole
- So did you spill it during the movie or?
- What was the movie
that you were watching?
- Before it started. I don't even know.
I can't remember I was just so,
I was literally distraught
for the first 40 minutes of the film.
I was actually just so sad.
- Well don't buy popcorn.
- I was genuinely when
it, when it fell over,
you know when you're so sad
about something bad happening.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You just sit there for like 10 seconds
and just let it soak about
how sad you are, you're like.
- All around me are.
- Yeah, Like you know when you break,
like you drop your phone and
it smashes you'll go like,
"Oh my God". You're like,
(Connor exhaling)
- You kinda just stare at it, right?
You don't even go to
pick it up immediately.
- You're just so overwhelmed
with emotions and sadness
that you just stand there.
- Yeah no, I get that.
- And like I had that moment.
- I get that feeling, but
not when I drop popcorn.
- I mean, I get it.
It's, it's whenever I drop any kind of
food item or drink item I've just bought.
- There's something, I've
broken my phone before,
I've broken expensive items.
And there's something
that just hurts so much
about dropping food or drink on the floor.
It can't be matched.
- There's nothing,
there's nothing that hurts me more
than buying a fresh pint and then like.
And then just like immediately dropping it
or like upon it just falling off the tray
as you're taking it to the table,
- I think I'd rather
drop my first born child
than my popcorn. If I'm
completely honest with you.
- Mainly 'cause I have Meilyne laughing.
- At least you can pick it back up.
- You know, the baby can
take a hit, you know.
I'm pretty sure I took a many hits.
My popcorn doesn't take a
hit. I can't eat that shit.
Right now especially if you pick that up,
everyone will look at you.
- Yeah, exactly.
- As much as I would want to pick up,
you know a part of me is like,
is the top layer of the popcorn
on the floor okay at least?
Can I at least scoop some of it back in?
- At least it's not directly touching it.
- It's like how much of
this popcorn has fallen out.
- I'm not gonna lie,
I want to say that I'm
hygienic. But if I see if, if.
- [Meilyne] You're not!
- Shut the fuck up. If like, let's say.
a bunch of nachos fell on the floor,
I would be tempted to just be like.
- No, not nachos.
Nachos is where I draw the line man.
I would be tempted to be like,
I would be tempted to be
like, the bottom layer
is cushioned.
- Scrape off the top.
- Is cushioned. Is cushioned.
I will grab the top left.
And I would eat that.
- No, ugh.
- Like popcorn comes in pieces, right?
Because popcorn, you can
scrape off the top layer.
So you could scrape off the layer.
- So you can get the bucket
that you have with it.
I would put, maybe I would like kind of
shuffle some of the top ones back in.
If they were, if they were in.
- Thought you floated up slightly so.
- Yeah, tilt it 40 degree angle
and see what I can like scoop
back in from the top layer.
Nachos for me, it's a little too wet.
- Nachos is way too wet.
- It's like chili, I
spilled chili on the floor.
Start grabbing.
- Scrape the top layer.
(hosts laughing)
- Like french fries right?
Let's say all the french
fries fell on the floor.
A part of me would be tempted to be like,
you know, the top 40% of these
french fries. Perfectly fine.
- Yeah. No, no. Of course.
- Imma start grabbing them.
- Okay 'cause one, okay
so there are two factors.
- I'm gonna sound so vile to some people.
- No, I'm the same. I'm the same.
- Okay, there are two
factors you need to consider.
One, what is the ground?
Is it like a clean?
- What is the ground?
- No no, because if it's like
- Carpet.
- Clean carpet
- Carpet is the worst.
- Carpet is the worst because
you've got like all shit
and like, you got all the dust and shit.
If you drop it on the street
floor, that's just like,
- Game over.
- Rest in peace.
- That is game over. You have
to say goodbye right there.
- Wood laminate flooring? Okay.
- Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Maybe.
- Maybe we can salvage most of this.
- Secondly you need to consider,
what is the food item that
you've just dropped? Right?
Is, is it liquid?
You know how, how, how
viscous is this food item?
- You need to get a straw.
- Like, like popcorn. It
comes in little pieces.
You can just, you can just like
scoop off the bottom layer
and just leave that on the
floor and just like it's,
it's like the safety layer
you have like the bottom layer
and then the safety layer,
just in case any of
anything on the second layer
touch the floor.
- In case the germs have
like made its way up.
- Yeah.
- Once you drop a
chocolate bar on the floor,
do you just like pick
it up and scrape it off
all the dirt?
- Chocolate bar.
- I'd do that.
- Chocolate bar. Honestly
it depends like it's,
- Get a rinse.
- it's a solid piece of food. Right?
So it depends on the
floor that its touched.
- I treat it like an NES
cartridge. I just kinda blow on it.
Just blow off the dust. It's like, yeah,
it's good enough.
(hosts laughing)
I've got an immune system for a reason.
- One week later.
We have the 'Rona and what went wrong?
- I wouldn't do it now
but like during high
school, like if I, you know,
like dropped a sandwich,
for example, right?
Like depending on how it landed,
like if the sandwich
perfectly lands on the ground,
that bottom piece of bread, RIP.
You'll take everything else.
- You're tearing that piece
off. Let's be honest right?
- I'm taking everything else on top of it.
I'm not wasting food, fuck that.
- No I kinda like how
you suddenly went from,
"Yeah, eww. Disgusting." to
"Wait, maybe. Wait maybe
there's a situation".
- I don't want to waste food, man.
- The point is I would
rather drop my child.
TLDR.
- TLDR.
- I'm pretty sure my parents dropped me.
I'm pretty sure I'm, I'm fine. Right?
- I don't think there's a single parent
who didn't drop their child.
Come on now.
- This is what, this is why
I am terrified of holding a child.
I don't think I've actually,
I don't think I've, in my
30 years of being alive.
I don't think I've properly
held a baby in my life.
- I've seen people in Japan
where they're on their bikes.
They have the kid in
the carriage behind them
and they have the kid
in the backpack on them.
And I'm like, this is just, this is
- [Joey] That's hard mode.
- This is an accident waiting to happen.
Like it feels sketch as fuck.
- Which ever way you
fall, you are cushioning.
- God Joey.
- Just kidding.
- I don't know, that's
why I never understand.
whenever you know,
one of my family members
has a baby or something
and they deadass look
me in the eye and go,
"Do you want to hold this baby?"
And I'm just like,
"Why would you trust?
"So why would you trust a
literal life in my hands?"
Like I don't trust myself to hold that.
Does this thing come with a
fucking instruction manual?
Like how do I operate this thing?
I don't fucking know.
- I always wonder like,
like I'm like, how do you,
do you like,
- You kinda like cup it, isn't it?
- Do you kinda like
take it from the bottom?
- As somebody who has many
pictures of me holding babies,
I can tell you,
It's like, do you take it from the bottom?
Or like under the arm?
- So you do it like this,
you like kind of like rest them like this.
- I know how do it now. But
like when I was like 14,
- Who told you how to do it?
I had no one's ever told me
how to properly hold a baby.
- Just maternal instincts isn't it now?
- Trial by fire.
- Many babies are sacrificed.
- I used to grab them by
the temple, like this.
Realized they didn't
like that when I started.
- 'Cause I think, I think because like.
I, I'm terrified of it
because every single time
bar none that I've tried to hold a pet,
it's tried to wriggle out.
And I'm just thinking,
"Shit, if this fucking
animal was trying to
"wriggle out of my grasp,
"I do not want to hold a human
life in my hands and risk
"dropping a human life on the floor."
- Babies don't wriggle.
They just complain.
They're like British people.
- I don't think I've ever,
I don't think I've ever seen a
baby like get held by someone
and be like, "Fuck off me".
- "What are you doing?"
- It's like, "No".
- Anyway, back to movies. What
were we saying about movies?
- The viewership sucked for the Oscars.
That was the overall part.
But then again like I feel like,
I feel like the Oscars
just can't win right now.
No matter what they do
that they're going to lose.
Like if they, if they,
if they patent it more
to or change the demo
and focus more on mainstream movies,
the movies people are actually watching,
I feel like the whole
integrity of, you know, the,
'cause you can't,
- The artistic integrity.
- You can't fucking give 10
Oscars to Fast and Furious like
as much as you know,
for the fact that,
the fact that the Harry Potter movies
never got an Oscar for anything.
for the whole movie run,
I do feel it's a bit of a shame
because I do feel during that time,
they were just kind of shunned.
The fact that they've seen
as just mainstream garbage.
And I genuinely think that Harry Potter
could have won in certain areas,
especially like, you know,
like set design.
Well there was so many times
that Harry Potter could have won an Oscar
and never did. And I feel
like a lot of disdain
was built up during that period where,
- Well, I mean, I feel like the Oscars
just has not aged well as time has gone on
because like.
- And then they got
caught up in the whole,
the whole woke culture.
Which I felt like when
you get into that debate,
you've just lost because
you're going to upset someone.
- Yeah. Because once you get in,
once you get into the woke culture debate,
then you lose whatever side you go on.
You lose whatever
- You're gonna make
enemies no matter what.
- side you pander on or
even don't pander on.
Or even if you say nothing,
you are still losing, you know?
And I feel like that was the start of
really the decline of the Oscars
along with just the fact that,
it's all kind of the same.
Along with the fact that,
the more years I've watched the Oscars
or the more years I, 'cause I,
I don't even like watch
the Oscars that often,
but like more years I've watched it
the more years I realized,
"Man, I just don't know
any of these movies".
- No you don't. Well, cause
I think they had a few years,
you know,
where there was a lot of
artsy films that were winning
which, you know, I'm
sure they deserve them.
But I think as a mainstream viewer,
most people fucking
don't know what that is.
- [Joey] No.
- Like what was the, what
was that one movie that I,
I there's a few,
there's been a bunch of movies
that just won Best Picture
and I'm like, what?
- [Garnt] Oh yeah.
- Like Parasite was the first movie
that won Best Picture that I was like,
I know that movie.
I've seen that movie.
Good movie.
But like a bunch of other
years I've been like, what?
What? What?
- Yeah. I mean,
I think the problem with
the Oscars for me is that
even if something wins Best Picture,
I mean Parasite was one of
the only Best Movie winners
where I was actually,
- I feel like everyone
was happy that it won.
- Everyone was happy with
that. That was the first thing.
When I, when I saw people actually happy,
like mostly unanimously be like,
"Yeah. Parasite deserves it.
It's a fucking great film".
Because most of the times
when I see a Best Picture
winner on the Oscars, I watch it
And I'm just like,
"Yeah, this is a, this is a
very much an Oscar movie".
And I can see why it's so highly rated,
but I just didn't find it
that interesting personally.
- This is what happened to, you know,
there's an institution that
goes on for too long. Right?
It's got all these built up, you know,
things that they've been doing
for years. Like the whole,
like if you want to be in the Oscars,
you have to do a bunch of dumb shit and,
and hold events for the people doing it
and basically just pay them.
- Pay them out yeah.
- Pay them to get considered for it.
And that whole shit is dumb.
That's not how it should be
done at all. I don't think any,
I don't think anybody wants a system
where to be included in an award show,
you have to, there's a, there's
a pay to win essentially.
I mean, obviously you don't pay to win,
but you pay to enter. Which I mean,
why not just make it so that
the best picture gets
nominated for Best Picture?
- Yeah, you literally have to like
win the hearts of the
judge by catering to them,
not by making something good,
which is like kind of ass backwards.
- Yeah. And it says something
when I think that like
somehow, you know, something like
the Crunchyroll Anime
Awards is a better system
than the Oscars.
where they have a mix of like fan vote.
And obviously if you do fan
vote, you can kind of guess
what's gonna happen.
- People are still salty.
- Right. But I think having
that kind of fan vote in the,
in the equation to say,
"Hey, this is what the fans are thinking".
Just letting you know.
- But it's also by making
a fan voting system,
it gets those fans to
actually watch the show.
- [Connor] Right it gets them involved.
- No, it doesn't.
- You don't think so?
- No, fans vote for what they watch.
They don't vote for every
show that's on the list.
- No, no but what I'm saying is like
they're more inclined to
actually watch the awards show,
to see who won.
If they vote for it,
- Definitely, I'd say
- More so than like
- Yeah more so.
- leaving it to an unknown
committee of people right?
To be like,
"This is the best film. No
one can argue about it".
- I don't know how many judges there are.
There's quite a lot. It's
like 500 or something.
I completely estimated,
maybe Ashley can you check
how many Oscar judges there are?
- Yeah I don't think,
is the exact number known?
- I'm not sure,
but I think having some
form of waiting, you know,
like 5% by the fan or just
something like where the fans
can kind of have some form of sway.
- Right like the Game Awards, right?
I mean, the game, the
Game Awards I feel like
I don't know the exact number
but I feel like it's like 10%
is like the fan voted part of the awards.
- That seems good to me. That's, why not?
- At least we know what
everyone else is thinking
you know? Even if,
'cause I feel like the Oscars
is everything I hate about
pretentious Hollywood
because it's, it's
it's putting these people,
it's putting this work on
like a fucking pedestal
where an award show should
be just about you know,
celebrating what everyone loved
that came out in the year.
I mean, it's, it's become like
this whole other political
message and fucking,
- Well yeah and I think
that's what happens when
the weight of an Oscar
becomes what it is. Right?
Like you can make your career
off winning an Oscar, right?
If you win one early on, I imagine your,
the amount you just start
charging people for your work
goes up significantly.
So it's understandable why it
all comes in, but it's just,
it's just,
- And that's why I've always enjoyed
other kind of award shows
like whenever Ricky Gervais
hosts the The Golden Globes,
that's just like,
- That's like rich people get roasted 4K.
(hosts laughing)
- Like I'd rather, I'd take that any day
over the Oscars.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- That's very good. I do enjoy that. Yeah,
because the Oscars is always
the same shit it's like,
"And now for somebody who worked hard,
"there have been struggles and sacrifices,
but they worked hard and won the award".
and it's like, great. This is like.
- As if everybody is not working hard.
- You know,
you could put all the Oscar speeches into
a learning algorithm and
I bet it will predict
what the next speech will be.
- Auto-generated Oscar acceptance speech.
- Generally, like it
feels like it sometimes
like you know, you got fucking Brad
because Brad Pitt did the
speech for Best Picture.
Oh no, it's a Best Actor, I think.
Or one of them, I don't
remember which one.
And. You know, it's
like, you have Brad Pitt
and then you give him this,
napkin-esque McDonald's, you know,
McDonald's like commercial
speech and it's like.
Why not get them to do something fun?
Why don't get them to do something
that'll get people interested,
like actually talk like properly.
I don't know. Just, yeah.
It's just like, I don't
want to fucking watch
a McDonald's ad read.
- Go on Ashley, how many people
were in the Oscar committee?
- [Ashley] The academy is made up of
more than 9,000 voting members.
- Jesus.
- All are film-industry professionals.
- Wow.
- Most are US-based. And almost
half are active filmmakers.
- So roughly 10,000 people.
- That is a lot of people.
- I do also think if
there is 9,000 people here
and judging who are
from the film industry,
that's also, also kind
of a problem in itself.
So the people who are
working in the industry
are the ones who had decided the votes.
- Because I guarantee
none of them are like
film critics or anything like that. Right?
- I mean, yeah, exactly.
- I mean there might be film critics.
- Maybe.
- But I mean,
if there's people who
are working on the films
that are voting, I think that's a problem.
- That's a bit of a bias happening right?
- A little bit you know?
Obviously you might not, I
don't know what the rules are,
- I mean to me, there is no perfect system
for like an award show right but.
- Either way, the way it is
now isn't working, clearly.
now is just not capturing
the public's like, interests.
- Interests.
- Also, why isn't it being
live streamed? Come on, Oscars.
We're in the fucking 21st
century, live stream this shit.
- How do people watch the Oscars?
Is it pay-per-view?
- It's on like US TV.
- It's on TV.
- Why is it not on fucking
YouTube or Twitch? Come on.
I want to PogChamp with the
fucking, could you imagine.
Best, Best Supporting Actor, And it's just
MonkaS right before it gets
announced. You know? Like,
- Pog!
- I want that, you know,
like Best Actor Shrek wins the Oscar,
just fucking like Shrek pogs in the chat.
Like, this would be fun as
fuck. Like what are you doing?
This is great. This is how
you get people into it.
Like if you could,
if you could do channel
points like gambling,
'cause you can do gamble, right?
Like I can do, I can do,
"Mods mods, do this thing
on my stream". Right.
"But do this prediction".
Like imagine if you can do that.
- I bet so-and-so is going to win. Yeah.
- Right when they're
announcing the nomination,
boom, the prediction comes in,
press your channel points.
You know what I mean? This is like, why?
- I mean, I feel like this
is why the Game Awards
is just so much more fun to me to watch
as like a viewer than any kind of film,
film award show or other
kind of award show.
- Absolutely.
- You can still stick all
the sponsors in. You can,
you can fluff the viewership numbers.
'Cause they'll definitely
be higher. You can,
you can do so much more like
it just to me it's like, yeah.
I mean, it's just the whole system of
just old systems in place that, you know,
have to answer to it
and all this nonsense.
- Yeah. Just not bothering
to change the system.
- Yeah. I mean, to me,
the Oscars has always been that thing
where it's just been on in the background
and people have talked about it,
but I'm just like,
"Yeah, I mean".
- When was the last time you
cared about who won an Oscar?
- I don't even remember. I
don't even fucking remember.
- "Shrek". "Shrek" winning Best Animated.
- I don't even remember
the last time I sat down
to watch the Oscars or the
Grammys or anything like that.
- Well you can't. Where
the fuck do you watch it?
You're you're not American.
- I mean, you can watch
it like back in Australia,
but not here anymore.
- I didn't even know where
to watch it in the UK.
- When was the last time
you cared about a winner
because I feel like before "Parasite",
I can't even, I can't.
- Shrek. Shrek winning
Best Animated Picture.
- I think the last time I cared,
- Did it actually?
- Yeah it did. "Shrek" won.
- Well no okay. Best Animated Picture.
I feel like that's a,
it's either going to be "Shrek" or,
- There's always Disney or,
- It's going to be either
Disney or "Shrek". Like wake,
wake me when an anime actually
wins Best Animated Picture.
- Well, "Spirited Away" won right?
- Yeah that's the only time an anime.
- That's the only time
that's probably the last
time I cared about it.
And that was like 2006
or something like that.
- I think that was 2002 or something.
- Was it?
- Surprised, "Your Name"
didn't win anything.
- It got nominated though.
- Did it get nominated?
- It did get nominated, but
it obviously didn't win.
- Yeah.
- This is so sad. Imagine this, PepeHands.
(hosts laughing)
They would have lost you know?
- Yeah I mean like the anime,
anime has always just been
fluffed by the Oscars.
No matter what. I mean,
wasn't it the one year that
"Boss Baby" got nominated
over "A Silent Voice"
- Yeah it did.
- or something like that.
- Let's go.
- I think as well, I heard that like
the only reason why "Spirited Away" won is
because like one of the
head people at Pixar,
like really, personally vouched for it.
- Yeah. I mean, I mean.
- They also, it got dubbed by Disney.
- Yeah yeah.
- Ghibli is the only thing
that's been noticed by,
no yeah, Ghibli's been the only thing
that's been noticed by Disney. And,
- Well because they certainly went,
"Holy shit. This is better animated than
"all of out stuff. What
the fuck? What's going on?"
- Holy shit. These guys are
still doing 2D animation?
- Yeah, what the fuck?
- That's fucking dedication right there.
- Yeah exactly.
- TLDR, nobody cares
about the Oscars anymore.
Till they live stream it
and I can do MonkaS.
- Live stream it, then
put me on in a week.
- Honestly, honestly I'd watch
because then people will be like,
if they let people like
live stream it as well
and watch it live,
man, their viewer
numbers would be massive.
- Yeah.
And maybe that'll get me to
watch more films as well.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I do, I do want to watch
more films. It's been weird
seeing films released online
on like HBO max
- I do not like it
- and stuff like that. Right?
- Yeah. I think it's,
it's just reaffirmed for me
that I just love the movie theater
and I love the experience
and that I hope that it never goes away.
- No it's great. Like I love
going to it, but it's like,
I'm not like you where I
can just watch anything.
Like it needs to be a
movie that I want to watch.
- I just enjoy the atmosphere much
that I will go and watch anything.
- I feel like there are some movies that
I would prefer to watch in
movie theaters than others.
- "Tenet"
- Like, sorry?
- "Tenet" maybe actually,
I feel like that would have been cool
in the movie theaters, but
I'd like any action flick.
I feel like it would be
better in movie theaters.
- 100%. Yeah.
- Like I feel like I
missed out on something,
not watching John Wick.
- Well those fucking car scenes in "Tenet"
where they're like going back in time
and zooming forward. It
was so good in the theater.
It was amazing. So good.
- I need to watch it this week.
- It's so good dude, you do.
- It's it's good. Just,
just for the visuals and
just because it's by far
one of the most visually interesting,
interesting like films I've ever seen.
- Super interesting. But yeah. I mean,
I want to watch more movies. I, I just,
I just really can't watch
movies at home because I,
I put it on, I see that
fucking two hour thing counting down.
I'm like, "That's a long time".
"That's a long time to focus, damn".
- To me, to me,
- Spend an hour and a half
watching YouTube videos,
like no questions asked.
- To me it's, I don't know
some, something about a movie
and it's, it's the commitment.
Like once I've put some movie on I'll,
I'll fucking watch it,
but it's, it's bringing myself to,
it's willing myself to even
put that movie on in the first place
that I find trouble with.
- Yeah. I'm like, I think to
myself, I'm like, all right,
I can watch this movie. It's
like an hour and a half.
But at the same time,
I could also watch like three
30 minutes YouTube videos
that I wanted to watch as well, you know?
I could do that. I think
I might prefer that.
- I could just watch random YouTube videos
for an hour and a half
that I don't really care about.
- I could watch like 300
20 second meme clips on YouTube.
- True, true.
I've been doing a lot of
that recently. Oh my God.
- I mean, that's, that's all,
that's been coming up on my recommended.
- I don't know what's going
on with YouTube recently,
but they just stopped
recommending YouTube videos
and started recommending
like YouTube shitposts.
It's like Twitter videos.
- Yeah legit. It's so weird.
- If I get a recommendation nowadays
and it's like above a minute, I'm like,
"Oh, this must be a
fucking special video".
Oh, okay.
- What was the one we watched
before we start recording?
- The Chonk Chart.
- That's my, that's my favorite video.
It's been recommended recently.
- That is brilliant.
- But now it's gotten to
the point now, where like,
even all the comment sections
can all agree on what,
like everyone is,
everyone's got recommended
the same playlist
'cause everyone's quoting the same videos,
even though they're like,
they're quoting a different
video on a different meme video.
And everyone gets a reference,
even though it's not
on any kind of playlist
or anything like that.
- Yeah.
- Well it's like people watch
two hours of Trash Taste
and not, and they'll be like,
"No movie for me. Two hour
Trash Taste podcast. Let's go".
It's like,
Oh wow. Okay. Thank you. I'm honored.
- Yeah. Thanks.
- Did you guys used to watch
more movies back in the day?
- A hundred percent. Yeah.
- Yeah. When I was like 15, I loved it.
But that was when you discover
like that you can watch things online.
So you can tell me,
I can watch any movie I
want by just typing the name
into Google. What the
fuck? Are you for real?
That was like a massive
revelation in my life. I was like,
Oh my God.
- Did you guys through go through that
IMDB top 100 movie phase?
- Oh yeah. 100%.
- Oh no, top 250 movie phase.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- You know what the first movie ever
I've watched illegally was?
- What?
- It was the Hannah Montana movie.
- How'd you remember this?
- I just remember that
was when I discovered
that you could watch it.
- Is that the one where it's like
the best of both worlds.
- I think so. I don't know
what it was, but I remember,
- It's like the one she
was on tour or some shit.
- Yeah, there was like
a dance to it as well.
- Yeah yeah.
- 'Cause I remember,
I remember that someone kept walking up
and getting up in front of the camera
for the movie.
(hosts laughing)
- Oh it's one of those, right right.
- So here's the thing, right?
This is like the more you get older,
the more you have money
that your, your tolerance for the quality.
So when you first, when you're like 12,
you will watch anything for some reason.
You're like, people standing
up in front of the camera,
shaky cam quality.
No problem. I'll watch it.
The moment you get it like a HD DVD rip.
You're like, I can't go back.
- It's like, 480p. Unacceptable.
- Why isn't this shaking?
Why is there no artifacts?
Why is no one standing up
in front of the camera?
What's going on? You know?
- Yeah, to me,
- Sorry I just remembered.
- Yeah to me it was always
like the ripped DVDs
that I, that sellers and
Thailand would just sell.
So we'd have like little
shops where you'd have like
just DVD cases.
- They still do that there though right?
- They still do that now right.
This episode of Trash Taste
is sponsored by LiquidIV.
- [Connor] When you push your body hard
or just feel run down,
it's extremely important to stay hydrated.
Making hydration a priority
helps us feel healthier
on a day-to-day basis.
And luckily with just
one stick of LiquidIV
and 16 ounces of water,
you get two to three times
the amount of hydration
as plain water got.
- [Garnt] I love hydration.
- What?
- You know sometimes, I
get a little hung over.
And when I say sometimes,
I mean a lot.
(hosts laughing)
And what helps me get through
the hangover is LiquidIV.
Unironically, I literally
drank it this weekend
'cause I was hung over.
- My personal favorite flavor
is actually the lemon lime flavor.
- Really? Mine's actually
the passion fruit flavor.
- Damn, good choice Joey.
- [Connor] Did you also know that LiquidIV
can provide two to three
times more hydration
than water alone,
containing five essential vitamins,
more vitamin C than an average orange
and as much potassium as a banana
and also healthier than
sugary sports drinks,
no artificial flavors or preservatives
and less sugar than an apple.
Made with clean ingredients, non GMO,
vegan and free of gluten, dairy and soy.
- Damn. That's a lot of hydration.
- So grab your LiquidIV in
bulk nationwide at Costco,
or you can get 25% off
when you go to www.liquidiv.com and use
code trashtaste at
checkout. That's 25% off
anything you order when you
get better hydration today
using promo code trashtaste
at www.liquidiv.com.
- Thank you very much LiquidIV
for sponsoring this episode.
Back to the video.
- I mean that's pretty from
the internet speeds
there in Thailand, right?
Are they fast in Thailand?
Does everyone have access
to internet in Thailand?
- I mean, internet speed
in Thailand are like
faster than some of them,
some of what I get in the UK,
at least for uploads.
- Really?
I mean, I mean, yeah.
I mean like upload speeds in the UK sucks
and most people won't.
- For some reason we,
we've been really cucked
on the internet speeds.
- I mean download, completely fine,
But like upload you get
like 20 max, isn't it like,
- Don't talk to me until
you went to Australia.
20 was like fucking luxury in Australia.
- It's just, it's just
weird seeing that like,
I was paying you know,
$70 a month in London,
but promised a hundred megabytes
down and six megabytes up.
I never got more than three up.
I never got more than 60 down.
- Dude, I paid 60 bucks
a month for 0.3 up.
But you live in a prison. So that's like,
- We still have copper
wire. It's ridiculous.
In like 2020, we have copper wire.
- Like I, I, no joke because when, when,
whenever I like lived in the
UK, I would be, you know,
I remember being a YouTuber,
being a YouTuber you'd
have to pay for like
the most expensive internet
available. So I'm like, okay,
who's, who's the most
fastest internet provider?
And at a time it was Virgin Media.
- Fucking awful.
- Yeah. And the best that they
could provide is like 20 up.
And when they say 20 up,
it's really like 10 up in
like the quieter times in the,
quieter times in the day.
And then I, I would like,
- And it's like fucking $200.
- Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Right.
And then I remember
living in the UK before,
like before, like I had
more American friends,
I'd see like screenshots of
people on Twitter being like
a hundred up, a hundred
down. And I'm just like,
this is obviously Photoshopped.
There's no way. There's no way.
- That is a fucking lie
and I won't stand for it.
- There's no way people
get this upload speed
on any kind of internet.
- It's just tragic. In
like places like Europe,
you can have, your
neighbor could have like
one gigabyte upload and down.
And just because the wire
stops at his house, you,
you and you're his
neighbor, you won't have it.
You have copper. I just,
I just couldn't imagine
not living in Japan with
this God-tier internet
that never breaks.
Nothing ever bad happens.
- You say God-tier internet.
I have shit internet compared to you.
- Bro my internet is just like,
Jesus came down and
fucking blessed my router.
- Wait, what do you have?
- au.
- au?
- Yeah.
- What speeds are you getting?
- One gig down like 400 megabytes up.
- I'm getting 70 down,
70 up at most on wire.
- Really?
- Yeah, for some reason,
my apartment's like
semi-new but even then they,
they apparently can only
do like copper, I think.
Or like some really outdated system.
- Because I'm on WiFi
and I get 500 up, 500 down.
- What the fuck am I on?
- I don't know what they gave you Garnt.
'Cause I upload like nearly
like half a terabyte of files
every week.
And that would actually just be impossible
on my old internet.
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
- So like right now it's like, oh,
that that video I just
filmed was 150 gigabytes.
Oh no worries.
It'll take four hours to upload you know,
it's like whatever it's crazy.
Like this podcast I upload every,
every day after we film it
and it's like 300
gigabytes of video files.
And uploads overnight while
I'm sleeping and I wake up,
my PC is on. It's all done. It's good.
- Meanwhile back in Australia
it's like, 800 meg file.
Give it eight hours.
Yeah. It'll be done by the morning.
- Exactly it's ridiculous.
- It's fucking tragic.
- But yeah. I mean, I
really appreciate it.
Back to the whole, watching
shitty quality stuff.
I recently watched "Chernobyl"
and I wanted to watch it,
you know, in high quality because I just,
- You can actually.
- Yeah. You can buy it on YouTube.
That's how I watched it.
- That's how you watched it?
I watched it on Amazon Prime
and I had to pay every
episode individually.
- Oh no.
- Yeah. I had to do that as well actually.
- But this is, this is how done I am
with not watching stuff
in like high quality
that I would rather pay
I think it was like $3 an
episode and it offered me,
did you want to pay a $1.50
for standard definition
or for $4 for HD?
I think you should be shot as a company,
whoever is in charge of the
decision deserves to be shot.
Right. Okay. I'm joking.
That's terrible. That is a joke by the way
- For legal reasons, it is a joke.
- This is a joke, obviously.
I'm just exaggerating.
Who, who on Earth is willing to spend like
$1.50 for standard definition,
but not the extra dollar.
It is so scummy of these companies to do.
Why would you downgrade the,
like, this is what I hate.
If you have a product and then
you downgrade it and sell it
on purpose. Like, no. No.
- Well, what I, what I wonder is like,
they obviously know no one's going to buy
the standard definition
because if you're buying,
if you're willing to
buy standard definition,
then you're going to be the
type of person who's probably
going to find other ways to watch it
rather than watch it
in standard definition.
- It just makes me
irrationally angry. Yeah.
Like I was, I was very much happy to pay
the 15 bucks to watch this whole
series. It was really good.
But I just hate the fact that one,
it made me pay for every
episode individually.
And I guess in some weird
way, give me a package deal.
Give me something.
- I think it's for the
people who are like, oh,
I watched two episodes.
Don't want to watch them.
- There should be some kind
of package deal for it.
- Yeah, of course.
- Seasonal TV show right?
- Yeah. I'm like,
I think, I remember I rented,
no idea why I did this
because again,
I don't know why I just can't be bothered
of doing the whole dance of
some, watch something online,
spend two hours trying
to find a link that,
that doesn't give you viruses.
I don't want to deal with that
shit anymore. Like it's just,
it's too stressful.
And the, watching movies is
already hard enough as it is.
I'm not, I'm not doing this.
I'm not doing this
dance anymore. I refuse.
I think I watched "Borat" on YouTube.
- Wait, really?
- You watched "Borat" on YouTube?
- I rented "Borat" on YouTube
because for some reason I
wanted to watch it again
because I wanted to, I didn't know.
- I don't think I've ever
rented a movie on YouTube.
- Don't, it was awful.
- Really?
- Because for some
reason when I rented it,
I was like, great.
It was only in like 480p, on YouTube.
- Really?
- Is, is that because it's an older movie?
- No I'm pretty sure that
"Borat" is at least in like
fucking 720 or 1080.
- I'd like to think so.
- Like, I'm pretty sure it
wasn't in 480. I was like,
"What is this? What is this?"
I don't remember looking at this shit.
- Did you, did you rent
the standard version?
- No, there was only one
choice. It was like three bucks.
- Yeah there's only one
choice, standard definition.
- And then also, I just
found it really interesting,
that YouTube actually tells you
how many views the movie has.
- Oh really?
- And it had like 20. On YouTube.
- It might not have
been legit in that case.
- No it was definitely like legit.
- [Joey] Really?
- Like it was legit and it was just weird
because I was like, "This is so strange".
- Yeah. I've, I've been well,
I've been watching a lot of
films on YouTube here in Japan,
because I find like,
if there's a film that's
not on Netflix or something
or Amazon here, it's
normally on Japanese YouTube.
I don't know why. It's like, I started,
I started watching "The
Wire" on YouTube because,
- Are you paying for it
all? You paying for it all,
like one by one?
- No I'm paying like season by season.
But like it,
because I tried to watch
"The Wire" in the UK
and it just was not available
on like any platform
that I was subscribed to basically,
if it's not on Netflix and
it's not an Amazon Prime,
I'm probably not going to watch it, right?
But I feel like here in Japan,
YouTube is like the golden child.
There was so many films here on YouTube,
so many TV series that are blocked off
when you're in like, western countries.
So yeah if you're in Japan, use YouTube,
there's a lot on YouTube.
- I feel like I'm repaying
my debts as a teen.
You know what I mean? Just
paying for all these movies.
- Punished with the standard definition.
- I sit there as I ordered my
300 yen "Borat", SD quality,
480p thinking, old Connor would have,
would have gone online and
found an HD version today.
No, here you go movie, billion
dollar movie companies.
Here's three bucks.
- But alas, I don't have two
hours to kill, to find it.
I'm going to have to deal with this.
- I just, I just don't care anymore.
I've just like, I, I, yeah, I dunno.
I, I value my time too much now.
I'm so busy now that the
thought of spending 10 minutes
to try to find a link. If I
get to the five minute mark,
I'm about to give up. I'm like,
"No, I'm not watching it".
You've lost. You've lost.
- But like 10 years ago it'd
be like, day seven. Still,
- I'd be like, "Maybe it's my location".
Changes VPN to other countries to try
and get a different Google
search. You know what I mean?
Like I would do whatever it took.
Like I remember I tried to watch the,
the documentary about Pepe
and I just, it was fucking,
I couldn't even find a place to buy it.
Like it was
- Really?
fucking impossible to try to
find this movie to watch it.
- Were you in the generation where you,
where people are watching
things on Megaupload?
- Yeah yeah.
- Do you remember,
do you remember the dance
you had to do with the
72 minutes time limits?
So for anyone to anyone too young to know,
so for anyone to anyone too young to know,
they used to be the site
called Megaupload, right.
Where people would upload, you know,
full TV series and full movies on it.
Now, most movies they're on time.
It's normally like at least
an hour and a half, right.
- A hundred minutes.
- Like a hundred, like a hundred minutes.
So Megaupload for a free
account had a time limit
of 72 minutes. And for
every 72 minutes you watch,
you had to wait 72 minutes to watch the,
to watch it again. Right.
- Such a dick move yet,
amazing marketing choice.
- Oh my God.
- It was such a dick move.
- Like I don't know,
was it because it was the only site that
was available for people?
- It was one of the only
file sites that was like,
"Welcome everything.
"Come on. Put anything you want on here."
- Yeah. And I remember, I
remember back in the day when it,
'cause this was when I
was still in university.
So I think back, back when
Megaupload was popular,
I don't think VPNs were as popular. Right?
- No.
- Because VPN would be like
the easy answer to this nowadays.
Right. And I remember
feeling like I was like,
so fucking five head where, where,
what I would do is our university
had like a private network
that we would connect to, to upload
like our files or upload our projects
and stuff like that.
And so what I would do is I
would watch the 72 minutes,
then I would connect to the, to the,
to the university internet
and start uploading on there,
- Was it like the edgy
room? Was it the edgy room?
- Something like that. Right.
And then that worked great
until I did something stupid.
I started blabbing my mouth about it.
(hosts groaning)
So unfortunately I
lived in a shared house.
So this 72 minute,
the 72 minute limit became
like five minutes where
everyone in our house
started watching Megaupload
and you use like the same network
and use the same, same IP address.
- Oh, rookie mistake.
- And yeah, that was,
and then I realized it's just much better
to live by yourself and just
not have to deal with people,
sharing your internet. Do
you remember having to,
do you remember trying to game online
on university internet?
- [Connor] It was terrible.
- And how fucking awful that was.
- Terrible. Yeah.
- That's a memory I don't
want to think about.
- I have like flashbacks of just
the ping going from 10 to like 500
- [Connor] Who's uploading porn?
- I mean, it wasn't even
that bad for me because like,
because of Australian interest,
our default ping was like 300.
So it was more like going
from like 300 to like 900.
- Yeah I remember when I
gamed with an Australian
and they were like,
"Yeah, I've got great ping".
"Oh, what is it?"
"Oh 300".
I'm like, that's not, by no
measurement is that a good ping.
- If you have below 250, you're like,
damn, this guy's paying for
like the premium internet.
(hosts laughing)
- I dunno. I, I feel that
a university internet
was just the most
temperamental thing ever.
But it was really cool 'cause I remember
that because a lot of them
use the eduroam network.
I remember one time I went to Germany
and I walked past the
university and I was like,
"Oh, I connected to the internet,
"I connected to that
university's internet."
'Cause I, it shared the same
ID for like WiFi or something
or something like that.
But if I walk past any university,
you get free WiFi when
you're a university student.
- [Joey] Wow.
- If it was using the same
network, which most of them
were I think in Europe,
it's really cool. Fun fact.
- (Garnt) Wow.
- Life hack.
- Life hack. Just, I
don't know, do something.
- Walk past the university.
- Just get free WiFi.
- Stop complaining. It's free.
- I actually have a really awkward story
about when I set up
the WiFi here in Japan,
- Go on.
- Story time.
- Obviously, obviously we, you know,
we just moved to Japan and
one of the hardest things,
especially when we moved here was fucking
setting everything up initially.
- Joey knows all too well.
- [Garnt] Joey knows all too well,
Connor moved here like
two weeks before me.
So Joey, Connor had the cheat sheet
of just having Joey set
up everything for him.
- I was like,
I wanted to get in first
with Joey. I was like,
"Joey, I need help.
"Garnt's coming. I know you're
going to be sick of Garnt"
- He went and perfectly planned
out where I'd be burnt out
right as Garnt was about to ask me.
- 'Cause like I could
see when you asked Joey,
like to help you set up,
I could see like the,
just the hope just wash over
his face and be like, "Oh,
"this is the last time Connor.
This is the last time".
And I remember when you were
talking about setting up
like your driver's license and like,
I could see Joey's just like,
"No, don't ask me Connor.
"I'm not going to do it."
- I'm not doing it.
- I mean, that I feel bad.
Luckily there was someone
else who I hadn't bothered yet
to help me with,
(hosts laughing)
- So yeah. So as I was
setting up the internet
as, as you know, I have like
really, really slow internet
compared to you guys. Right.
- Peasant.
- Peasant internet. I can't
remember who I'm with.
It's not au, it's the other,
- Softbank?
- No, it doesn't really matter.
- It doesn't matter but they have the,
they have like English support,
which is why I picked them. Right.
Because I had to, I had to try
and sort this out by myself.
So when they said they
have English supports
it's it's the most.
It's basically just like,
here's a person who translates
using Google translate.
Right?
- Japanese companies that
are like English support or
for foreigners only,
95% of the time,
it's just someone who doesn't
really speak good English
and it's just a way for
them to hike up the price.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- [Garnt] Oh yeah.
- Like if you go to the like,
what is it like, GaijinPot,
is that what it's called?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like that, that real estate website,
if you go and find the same
properties on a Japanese
website, they're much cheaper.
It's just like,
- It's like 30% cheaper at least.
- And it's just like,
(Connor exhales)
- Okay, it's being taken
advantage of because you know,
- They do do that.
- Just ask someone who's
Japanese to help you
you'll save a shit ton of money,
but you might lose a friend.
But you'll have at least saved
a few hundred bucks.
- Just make a Japanese friend
to eventually lose said Japanese friend.
- Pay him the money that you saved.
- Honestly, there should be a service
for someone to help you.
'Cause that would have, that
could save you a lot of money,
- Someone start a service.
Hire a Japanese who speaks English
to come with you to stuff.
- Basically.
- That's my first really, right there.
- Like the reason I was able
to set up my phone was 'cause
luckily, my cousin was here
at the time and I asked,
I asked her to do it and she works for JAL
so she can speak pretty fluent Japanese.
And she helped me set it
up. Perfect. No bumpy roads.
Setting up the internet
was a fucking nightmare.
- I have one on my phone.
So I'll tell mine after yours.
- Okay. Because like, firstly,
you, firstly like you have to,
set up with the internet
provider and then also set it up
with something else as well.
- I didn't have to do that for mine.
- You didn't, you didn't have to do that?
- Because I, I've like,
I get billed from two companies
and I don't exactly understand.
- Bruh. Bruh.
- That sounds like a scam.
- No, no, no. It wasn't a scam.
I made sure I wasn't a scam because
- How would you know?
- Because I, I,
- Because his English support.
- No, no because
- The Google translator
surely wasn't a scam.
- Not a scam.
- Microsoft tech support.
They were very nice.
They assured me that my Windows PC,
- There was an Indian guy on
the phone. They assured me.
(hosts laughing)
- I pay through Google
Play cards. You know,
it's totally legit.
- From what I understand,
you have to set up with like the ISP,
the person who provides the ISP.
- I did not have to do that.
- And then the guy, I think
'cause I think au provides both services.
Whereas my, my company did not
provide both services at once
- Yeah I think yours is like
Yahoo Mobile or something
right? Where it's like.
- Yahoo Mobile.
- It's probably like a, it's probably like
a version of like Yahoo
or something like that.
'Cause I remember I had that
and I had to do something similar.
- Yeah. 'Cause,
'cause the person that provides the line
and the person that like
installs the router,
and rents out the router
and stuff for you,
it's like two separate companies.
- Rents out the router?
They're like fucking 40 bucks.
- Yeah. I know. No, no, no.
But the thing is you can rent one out
and have them set up for you
or you can set it up yourself.
And so I chose, no, with
the internet option I had,
I didn't even have that option
because I would have loved
just to rent out a router
and have the engineer set it up.
No, I wasted a day
trying to figure out how
to set up my fucking router
and connect it to the
ISP engine in Japanese
and Japanese menus and everything.
It was, it was fucking hell blah, blah.
But before that, I had to even just
set up the deal that I was getting. Right?
And so I phoned up and I'm just like,
Okay. Yeah, I'm living here.
I choose, I choose the English option.
And even then it's, it's like,
- It's rough.
- It's a fucking rough kind of,
kind of like, it took me,
I think an hour of, an hour phone call
to communicate 10 minutes worth of stuff.
And just to make sure that
everything was correct.
And I tell them all my details
and so we're going through it.
And then they, they tell
me that, "We're sorry,
"this is the fastest internet
you can get at this house at
"this apartment". And I'm just like,
that's like your lowest option
that you have on your website.
'Cause they have like,
they have like different tiers, right?
They have, they have like the,
high paying option and they have like the
fucking peasant option.
- As they always. As they always.
- As they always do.
And they were like,
"We're sorry, you can only
get the peasant option".
- Why?
- And I was like asking why. Right?
And they were saying, they told me that,
"I'm sorry, your building
is not new enough.
"And yeah, it doesn't have the
newest internet installed".
- Yeah. That's the problem
with Japanese internet
is that like it, depending on the building
and the wires built into it.
They just like,
"We can't do it. Sorry."
- Yeah. So,
- It's ridiculous.
- So I was like, there's
no way that this is true.
Because I my,
my apartment's pretty
modern. It's like it's,
it's I think it was built,
- It's newer than mine.
Much newer than mine.
- Yeah it's newer than yours.
And I heard about the
speeds you're getting.
So I was like, I was like,
- [Connor] No problem.
I was like doubt.
- [Connor] Fuck Connor.
- Where is this phantom speed coming from?
- Yeah. I was like, doubt.
- I'm actually stealing the
next door building you know.
- So, so, so like, so like I'm just like,
let me consider this deal right?
So I, so I hang up,
I phone out the next day
so I could talk to
someone different. Right?
So I can just make sure that,
- It wasn't just that person.
- It wasn't just that person
that I was miscommunicating to.
Right. So I phone up, I go through
the same fucking hour phone call
that doing it again, explaining,
"Yes. I just want to make sure
"that this is the best
option I can go for.
"This is the best option and
there isn't a higher option."
And, and the second person that
I was talking to, she goes,
"Hold on a second. Let me
just talk to my manager".
And so she gets her manager
and her manager comes on.
It's the same fucking guy
I talked to yesterday.
And so I was just like,
- [Connor] Noooo.
- "Yeah, can I just make sure
"that this is the highest
option available?"
And he goes,
"You're the guy that phoned
yesterday didn't you?"
- Aren't you?
- And I was like,
"Yeah, this is, this is awkward.
"Can I just double, double make sure?"
And he's like, "Yeah. I
mean, I just made sure again,
"it's the best option available and,"
- This motherfucker.
- I wonder,
I wonder if you tried a
different internet company.
- I wanted to. and so I, I go,
I go through the ordeal again and I,
you know, give them all my details again.
And this time I actually have to send my,
send my ID or scan my ID just
to make sure everything's all,
everything's all kosher.
Shit you not, first bill I get.
Right. I open up, Grant Maneetapho.
(Joey laughing)
I send them my ID
so that they can verify
my name and address.
And they. And they fucking
auto correct my name again.
- Grant Maneetapho
- No, no, no. His name on
the ID must've been wrong.
- No, no, no.
- A lot of fucking idiots in the UK.
- I think the visa people
just spelled it wrong.
- Fuck the visa people.
Fuck the government.
- What the fuck's a
Garnt? That's not a name.
- So what, you just
bought the shitty internet
and it's shit?
- Yeah. I mean,
- I'm sorry. I bought the shitty internet.
It turns out it was shit.
- So yeah. I mean, I couldn't be bothered
to fucking go through another like
two hour phone call with another company
and I just settled for it. And,
- I mean, trust me, like,
even if you were perfect in Japanese,
it probably would've taken
just as long like 'cause
my God.
- Well actually when Joey
helped me try to get my
internet and SIM card.
And originally I got
internet and a SIM card
with the same company.
Turned out the SIM card just
didn't work on my phone.
And 'cause they were like,
"Oh, we don't sell this
model of phone in Japan".
So in, in Europe,
I don't know if it's the same as the US
but you can basically
buy SIM cards anywhere
and they'll work with every phone.
Like it doesn't matter what it is.
You just put it in. It works.
Yeah. But yeah,
apparently that's not the case in Japan
because of course it isn't.
I found out that Japan is
the only country on Earth
that uses the very specific
type of like, bandwidth
or whatever it is that
the phone lines use.
So a lot of phones don't work in Japan
because Japan was like,
"No, no, no, we're going to be different".
And it's like,
"Of course you are Japan".
- Of course you are.
- Everything's gotta be different.
And that's why like getting a phone here
is fucking hell.
And that's why like SIM
cards is so expensive.
I think recently they
did something about that.
They're gonna change it
because I think the government is like,
it's getting out of hand,
like the prices of phone,
phone carriers here are ridiculous.
- I mean, I'm paying more for my phone
than I am my internet.
- Yeah. Me too.
I'm paying 90 bucks a
month for my fucking phone.
And that doesn't include,
that doesn't include the phone.
That's, I bought the phone myself.
- I think I'm paying like 70 bucks a month
and I get like
4 gigs of data.
- [Connor] It's insane.
It's insane. It's like, what is this shit?
This shit is stupid. This
is way too much for shit.
It's okay. It's good.
But I mean, it's good service, but,
- It's good but.
- But it's shit. But it's shit
that they're charging
me this much. I paid,
I paid $15 In the UK for what I was,
10 pounds, for what I was getting.
- I think I paid like 20
pounds a month in the UK.
- That's expensive.
- For like unlimited data.
- Yeah it's ridiculous.
- And when in the UK,
when they say unlimited data,
they actually mean unlimited data.
I've never been throttled
in my data in the UK at all.
- The speeds are fantastic
here. Don't get me wrong,
- [Garnt} Speeds are great.
- But not to the point where we're at
we're talking a hundred
dollars a month speed. Come on.
It's more than my internet bill.
You're having a bit of, come on,
a bit of a joke.
I mean it works really
well, but I just, yeah.
And that's why like a lot of people I know
don't even bother getting SIM cards
because you have to sit there for like
four hours talking to them, asking,
answering dumb questions.
And they're trying to
sell you a ton of stuff.
Like, 'cause I think
Aki doesn't even use a,
- No, she still has an American thing.
It just pays for pocket WiFi.
Because she's just like she looked at like
all of her friends getting, you know,
the SIM cards and whatnot,
she's like,
"I'm not going through
that shit. Fuck that."
- It's hell,
but I just don't want to
have to charge a fucking
portable WiFi thing all the time.
Having a Japanese number
does help sometimes
and things like a lot of forms require you
to have Japanese numbers for some reason.
- Yeah she just uses
my number for that so.
- Wow isn't that convenient?
Where's my Japanese
fucking fluent boyfriend
who translates and does
everything for me huh?
- Yeah. No, if I were her,
I would totally do the same
thing to be honest. Yeah.
- Honestly like, the only reason
I wanted a phone was because
I didn't want to carry
an extra thing with my
phone just to get WiFi.
- [Connor] Same, same, same.
- And you're like not carrying like
a purse with you all the time.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's just annoying.
- Exactly. Exactly. But yeah.
I know several people who
just have pocket WiFi here,
just 'cause it's
they don't want to go
through the trouble of
switching their phones or,
- Well I mean Reina still has pocket WiFi.
She's been living here for
like however many years.
- It's insane. Do we even have?
Pocket WiFI isn't popular
in like Europe I don't think
and in the US it's like not mainstream.
- I'd never really heard
of it until I moved here.
- It exists but like it's, it's not,
- It's not common.
- Nearly common as you see here,
because clearly they've made
a market where the phone,
the cell phone carriers
are so fucking awful
that there's a whole
industry about avoiding them.
It's ridiculous.
And the price of these pocket WiFis
are much cheaper than the cell phone.
- Much cheaper, yeah.
- It's just stupid.
- Like I legitimately dread
whenever I have to sort out like
the smallest thing within
like my living situation
here in Japan.
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- Cause like they,
I don't know how they all
somehow always turn like
a five to 15 minute meeting
to like a fucking hour long.
An hour long ordeal.
- I'm waiting for the day
where you know how sometimes
when you get on a website,
if you change your email,
they'll be like,
"Please come in-person
to change your email".
And it will be like four
hours. And it's like,
I could've just done this online.
- Okay. Fucking Japanese banks, man.
I, I'm about to go fucking mad.
(Joey laughs)
- Oh God, he broke the table. He's so mad.
- Jesus Christ.
- I have so much salt towards,
- Foreigners complain
about Japan, volume 10.
- Honestly, Japanese banks.
- Do you want to preface
before we get into this?
And we do love living in
Japan, very kind country.
But we are British and we
complain about everything.
I complain about everything in the UK.
- I'm an innocent bystander in this case.
- Oh bullshit. Like you don't
complain about the banks.
- We complain about everywhere we live.
And especially if something
like is inefficient to a Brit.
You know, we, we will
happily wait in line.
But if,
if that meeting takes any
seconds longer than it needs to,
we are, we are going to
complain the shit about that.
So, so Japanese banks, we have to fucking,
since our visa only lasts six months,
we have to re, we have to
go to the bank every time
to tell them not to
cancel our card. Right?
And the thing about Japanese banks is that
you can do fucking nothing
on the phone. Right?
So just, just so they don't cancel a card.
Every time my visa runs out.
Every time we renew our visa,
we have to go there in person.
And not just any branch of our bank,
we have to go to the,
- Branch that you
started the bank account.
- We have to go to that specific branch,
which if you don't live
anywhere near the branch,
you open your bank account.
You're pretty much fucked.
- Yeah.
- They didn't give me a warning.
They didn't tell you why.
So you could be stranded
in the middle of fucking nowhere in Japan
and not be able to get any money out.
'Cause they've, they've canceled your card
and not told you.
- Yeah. And another thing is,
I needed to go there for like,
I needed a bank statement. Right?
You think for a bank statement,
that's a pretty normal,
- Just go on the app, go online.
- That's a pretty normal
document you can obtain
from a bank. Correct?
So I go to the, I go to the bank
and I asked for a bank
statement and they have like
fucking 70 million different
kinds of bank statements.
And I'm just like, what?
How hard is it to?
- Tommy, Tommy money go in, money go out.
Print money go in, money go out.
- What is the document where you can see
money go in, money go out transactions?
You spend money here. I
just need that document.
And they're like,
"Okay, maybe we can do that."
- Maybe.
- Let's see. They go, they go, they go in.
- I gotta go talk to
the manager about that.
- Literally. Literally they
go, they talk to the manager.
They give me like two forms
to fill out and go and go.
"So are you okay getting
this in three weeks?"
Um I'm like,
"Is there any faster way
to get this document?"
And they're like,
"No, if you, if you want this document
"because you didn't sign up for it before,
"you have to wait three weeks
"and we'll send it to you.
"Now, do you want this document monthly?
"Or do you want us to like, just hold it?"
And then I'm like,
"No. From now on give me this monthly."
because there is no other
way to obtain a statement if,
unless you just go to
the bank and ask for it
and you have
to ask for this option when
you sign up for a bank account,
or when you,
when you realized that
you need a bank statement
for whatever, you know.
- What is the point of like
the 900 printers that
they have back there?
- I know.
- Like, what are you
using these printers for?
- Paper airplanes yeah.
- And so I'm waiting for this
document for like, for like,
'cause I needed to file some stuff.
I needed a bank statement.
It took five weeks for it to get sent.
I didn't realize when
they said three weeks,
they meant three, like three,
- Three weeks minimum.
Basically Japanese banks.
I don't know if we've
just been really blessed with UK banks.
- Our banks are really good in the UK.
The apps work amazingly.
- The apps work amazingly.
You can just transfer money on an app.
It's pretty, it's pretty secure.
And I can have my statements if I,
I have like three to four,
no fucking five years
worth of like bank
statements that I can have.
- Download them in PDF. Do
whatever I want with them.
- No Japan has those as well.
Like I use a bank currently
that has a great fucking app
and I can do transactions all on my phone.
The problem is, they're
not the major banks.
All of the major banks are like,
"You have to go in, in person,
"bring your fucking stamp and
sign like 17 pieces of paper.
"And we'll send you
something in two years."
- Yeah because I've
wanted to transfer money
back to my UK account for like, since,
since I moved here. I just don't,
I'm just dreading the ordeal
I have to go through just to
just so I can move money
from one place to another.
- It's like a whole day event.
- It is. It fucking is.
- When it should be five minutes long.
- Like every time I go to the bank,
I lose at least an hour or two of my life.
- That's unfortunate that like things
that should take 10 minutes
or 15 minutes, tops,
are always like four hours in Japan.
That's where the frustration
comes from where it's like,
you've put middlemen and checks in places
where there didn't need
to be any, you know?
And it's just,
- It's like, why do you
have to ask your manager
if this dude needs a bank statement?
- Everything and anything you do,
they will always ask
the manager. It's like,
do any of your employees
have the ability to do
anything on their own?
- Are your employees like trained at all?
Just make a fucking decision for yourself.
Jesus, what are you employed for?
- Yeah I mean like, by the
time I got the statement,
the statement was like already out of date
because it was a month
old statement. Right?
So I had,
I had to, fuck.
I like fucking begged because,
'cause I was filling
out tax stuff and I was,
I was fucking begging my
accountant and be like,
please let this be like, please,
please let this be usable.
'Cause I don't want to
fucking do this again.
I don't want to go
through this ordeal again.
- I want to wait five weeks again.
- I think the most
frustrating part about it
is that when you're like,
please help me with this thing,
they make it seem like
you're the weird one
for like wanting to like,
make stuff go quicker
or do things simpler.
They're always like, "Why
would you want to do that?
"This is the way we do it."
- Yeah. This is, this is
the, this is the way that
where it's a hundred percent success rate.
So I was like,
why else would you make it any other way?
- Well, I remember, cause I think,
I think Dogen did a video about
the Japanese banks as well.
He did and he mentioned something else
one time where he was like,
sometimes you just have
to tell them like, no.
Like just tell them no,
that's not going to work.
And then maybe be like,
you have to do this or help me do this.
And the manager might be like, okay.
But it's sad. Isn't it?
That sometimes you have
to put your foot down
to get anything done here.
It's just terrible. It's just so sad.
- It's that you have to
like pull tooth and nail
to get the best service that they offer.
- Right. Which is why I hate,
sometimes I feel bad when I ask
Japanese people to help me
with it. 'Cause if I'm like,
"Can you ask them to do this?"
Like, "No, no, no, no.
"They don't do that here."
It's like, if you have a foreigner friend
they'll at least ask, they'll be like,
"Hey, can we do this?"
But if I'm asking a
Japanese friend to help me,
like who's a hundred percent
Japanese and you know,
fluent in English somewhat, I'll ask them,
"Hey, can you ask them this?"
They'll just be, they won't even ask
'cause they'll be like,
"No, no, no, no. You can't ask them that".
I mean look, just ask, just ask.
Like try, you know. I don't know like,
- That's such a Japanese way
of thinking though. Right?
Because they don't want to,
like embarrass themselves.
- They don't want to ask
questions that they feel,
they already know the answers
to because they feel like that
that's like humiliating at times.
Whereas I think I always
have the mindset of
there's no harm in asking.
- Right.
- Yeah I, I never thought
I would go to a place
where it's like, it's like a 50/50 on
whether you'd be able to get
a fucking credit or debit card. Right?
- Well I got rejected for all my cards
in the start.
- Yeah, exactly. Right?
- I had to apply two, no.
Two or three times until I
finally got a debit card.
- Really? Fucking hell.
- And it was like the worst one.
- So, so yeah. So in Japan, right?
When, whenever you sign
up to a bank account
in most countries that I know,
you get a fucking debit card.
- Oh yeah you too. This is so,
- Yeah yeah. So,
in most other countries
you get a debit card
in which you can spend your money,
which you put in your bank.
In Japan. they're like,
"We do not do that here."
- We do not want you spending your money.
- We'll give you a bank card.
- Well, they will give you a cash card,
- A cash card yeah.
- In which you can take
out money at the ATM
and also charge you a fee for
taking money out of the ATM.
So when you go to the,
when you go to the ATM and get money out,
you better be taking a
large amount of money out.
Otherwise you'd just be
like fucked for fees.
- Oh, by the way,
you can't pay with anything
with the cash card.
This cash card can only be used
to take out cash from ATMs.
You also can't take out any
money with your debit card.
Debit card can only be
used to pay with things.
- Yes. Of Which if you
apply for a debit card,
you have the possibility
of being rejected.
I, like, why? Why? Why?
Like credit cards, maybe?
- I understand credit cards
'cause it's like, you know,
you're using their money.
- But like for most countries I know like
fucking America,
they give out credit cards
like they give out free candy.
You know like,
- Oh yeah. Same in the UK, same.
- Same in the UK like,
- 'Cause they want you to get in debt.
So they can make your life hell,
take you for all the money.
- It's like, "Do you
have a pulse? Brilliant.
"Here's a 2000 pound debit",
- You joke but that's how it is.
- That is how it is.
- All the credit card companies
make all their money off the people who
are failing to pay back
their credit cards.
Like that's where they
make all their money from.
- Yeah in Japan, it's just like,
"Oh, you want to pay for
stuff not using cash?"
I don't know what, I don't
know about that one chief.
- It's like, if
I'm paying for like my
rent or something or I pay.
I don't want to pay in cash.
Why do you make me pay in cash?
This is like $1000. Don't
make me carry $1000 around.
I don't want to do that.
- After paying the ATM fee.
- Yeah so like, I tried
to buy a new camera
and my card, my debit
card had a limit on it.
I didn't know that.
How do I change the limit?
Gotta fucking call them up haven't I?
Oh for fuck's sake.
- [Joey] Of course you do.
- There's not an app
or anything I gotta do.
I gotta call them up, explain to them.
And they're like,
"Why would you want to
increase the limit?"
None of your fucking business
why I want to increase.
It's my money. I want to
use it. What do you mean?
- Yeah it's, it's,
it's like now that I've
lived here for like
one and a half years, I've realized that
it would be more convenient for me to use
my foreign card here
than it would have been
to like set everything up.
'Cause like the fees that they charge you,
whenever you take money
out, it's exactly the same,
like it's about the same fees they use.
- Sometimes.
- Sometimes yeah.
- And the only real difference I feel
is like the exchange rate.
You know, that, that
obviously goes up and down.
- You get fucked by the exchange rates.
That's why I always,
that's why I wanted the
debit card. 'Cause I was,
I was like losing a lot
of money 'cause I was,
I was having to use my,
my British card and I
was just losing money
on exchange rates and fees.
- Because the pound is so
strong compared to the yen.
- Yeah like right now,
I want to use as much yen as possible
because the rest of my money is in pounds
and it's really strong and
I don't want to use that.
I want to get rid of the
weak money that I have like,
spend it all, spend it.
- But like in, in that
case it would be like,
it's way more convenient to
use like a third party company,
like Revolut or like
TransferWise, like get it.
'Cause you can actually
get like a physical card
where you put money into this account.
- Well yeah I used to have one.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I used to have a card but
when the UK left the EU,
I lost that card and then they
stopped banking within the UK
so I had the one good card that I had
that was perfect for transferring
for using foreign exchange was
just useless after a while.
Big sad.
- Well look at us talking
like adults about credit cards
and banks and whatnot.
- Well it's just sad because
they've made a system that
makes it hell at every turn
and you need to answer for
every, like little things
that you've just like, comfort
or you have to explain why you want them.
I shouldn't have to explain to you
why I want to up the limit
on my card. Like that,
that should be a me. Why do
I have to tell you? Like,
well I'm getting interrogated
because I want to buy a fucking
camera. Like, what is this?
I don't like this. I, I,
it's not that I don't mind telling them.
I'm like it's for a camera.
But the fact that I have to
answer to you, like, like what?
Like if it's for like a
couch that you don't like,
you'll say no, fuck you?
- That's an ugly ass couch. Fuck that.
- Yo send me the link.
Let me check this out.
Yo really? The thread count
on those sheets suck bro.
I'm not upping the card. What? What the?
Why are you asking me this? Is there,
is there a situation where you like,
I'm gonna launder my money.
Well then of course
you're going to say no,
'cause I'm fucking doing
something illegal. When,
why is this ever going to work? Like,
what is this point of this question?
Don't ask me this shit.
You're making conversation.
If so fucking stop.
- We want like UK banks.
I just got a text the
other day being like,
"We've upped the limit
on your credit card."
And I'm just like,
Well, I didn't ask, but.
(hosts laughing)
I guess.
- Cheers.
- But UK banks are always really good.
They update me all the time
you know. The app is fantastic.
I can transfer money to anyone.
No questions asked you know.
- Well, I mean like
fucking bank apps are like,
I think only, maybe like
a thing that was invented
two or three years ago here.
When I first moved here like
none of the banks had an app.
- Yeah. Did you have online
banking when you moved here?
- No.
Literally I and I still don't
have it here because it's a,
because it's fucking horrible.
- I don't know how to transfer
money online in Japan.
I still haven't figured
it out. I don't know.
- Well I mean, some banks
don't even let you do it.
I don't even know if it's possible.
All I know is that
somehow when I buy things,
- Have you been able to log
in into your online banking?
- I've logged in.
So the online banking that
I have to send money is like
I, okay. I have logged into my bank,
but if I want to send money,
it's through like a different,
it's through my card.
It's really weird. Again, this whole shit.
It's been separated.
I don't understand what's going on.
It doesn't make any sense.
Japanese banks suck, please, please.
This is why, if you're a
tourist, you got it lucky man,
you don't have to deal with this stuff.
This is why everyone says Japan
is the best place to visit,
worst place to, not
worst place to live but.
- No, it's, it's, it's
an amazing place to live.
- It's an amazing place to live.
There's just a lot of things
that I took for granted
that I thought were just
little conveniences or just,
just the way the world works
in first world countries I guess.
- You get mega angry
and then you go outside,
you go to Matsuya and you get
your matsuya and you're like,
Nice. All right.
- Lots of little distractions
- It's all worth it but for that one day
when you're dealing with this stuff,
you're like,
I'm finna book a flight home.
I'm getting real tired of this.
- Actually no, 'cause it's not just Japan.
'Cause, 'cause I've lived
in Thailand as well.
And even they've got their
banking system more convenient
than they do. And I've
got, I got, I have an app.
That's all I can transfer my
money in my Thai bank account
to my Japanese bank
account if I wanted to,
I can't do that in Japan.
And Japan is a first world country.
Thailand is like a second world country.
- When I left the UK,
closing everything and
getting everything all sorted,
moving, everything I needed to do.
I did everything in like half a day.
Just making phone calls, just being like,
"Hey, can I do this? I'm, I'm leaving."
They're like, "Oh yeah,
totally fine okay."
Can I do blah blah blah?
Yeah, it's all good.
Or every phone call lasted
like at most, the whole,
the being on hold took
longer than the phone call.
It was like, it's so easy.
Like it's, it's so frustrating.
- Whereas here it's
like, oh you're moving?
- Oh you're moving? That's
a whole month process.
That's not because you got to
unpack and move stuff around,
that's because you got to go to the,
- You gotta call up and go to
fucking in store everywhere.
It's ridiculous.
- So absurd. So again, we complain a lot
about these aspects of Japan,
but you know,
we are very grateful to Japan
for allowing us to be here.
- I mean, there's a reason
why you don't just leave.
- Yeah we love it. You know,
- We're probably going to stay here for.
- I'm going to be living
in Japan for a long time.
I just, you know, I think
that when you live in a place,
you have the right to
complain about certain things.
- Absolutely.
- I complain about everywhere equally.
You everywhere socks, everywhere sucks.
- Exactly. There's no utopian country.
- Yeah, exactly.
And so, you know,
I don't want people to get the idea
that we're not fucking grateful.
Or we're not like happy.
- Because sometimes we get
comments like that sometimes.
- We do get comments like that sometimes.
And we are very happy here in Japan.
- We're just being real
with you guys that's all.
- We just, we just like to complain
about the little things.
You guys like it when
we're annoyed about shit.
That's why we're annoyed about shit.
- If you guys are going
to move to Japan. I,
I want to be honest with you
and tell you what's going to be fun
and what's gonna suck.
- There's going to be,
there's going to be lots of
fucking great things about it,
but just be prepared for
those little conveniences.
- Whenever you have to do
anything to do with like
Japanese bureaucracy or just setting,
setting up your living situation. I, I,
- You will be writing your name, address,
and phone number more times
than you'll ever think.
- You will lose at least a
week just trying to figure out.
- Yeah I think that's
the thing that annoys me.
In the UK when I had to deal
with this stuff, it was,
it was maybe an hour
out of my day at most.
And I'd get on with my day.
If it happens here, it
derails your whole week,
like it takes a completely,
you have to reschedule everything,
cancel everything you're doing
because you've got a call from the bank
and they said that your card is canceled
and they didn't tell you
until now it's canceled.
- I just remembered, like,
I don't know if you guys have in the UK,
but like in Japanese
and Australian airports,
there's like sometimes
that service where like,
you know how on your suitcase,
you can put like a belt around
it so it doesn't burst open.
Some people forget that or,
you know, don't buy that.
- I've never had to use that.
- No.
- So instead you can, like,
you can use a service that
you can like wrap up your bag
in like plastic.
- [Connor] I see that in the UK. Yeah.
- In Australia it's like
10 seconds you just like,
wrap this up. Here's the money.
They do it. All right. See you later.
I did it in Haneda once in Japan.
And they were like,
"Okay, can you fill out this form?
"Write your name, address
and phone number."
I'm like, I'm never
going to see you again.
Just wrap up my goddamn bag.
- Get the fucking cling
film out, wrap it around
and I'll give you 20 bucks.
- I like deadass, I looked
at this woman. I was like,
what do you need this for?
Like, why do you need to know my name,
phone number and address?
And they're like,
"Oh you know, like just in case."
I'm like, because you're
wrapping my bag in plastic.
- I'm a customer.
I will do it myself.
Give me the cling film.
- Yeah give me the cling wrap.
I'll fucking do it myself.
- I will pay you to not fill in that form.
- It was ridiculous.
- It's frustrating, man.
- And I just wasted, like, you know,
two minutes of my life filling
out this form, that for one,
I don't even know what
they're going to use it for,
but second of all, completely unnecessary.
- It's just frustrating
giving out your whole
fucking information to,
to shit that you feel like it
just totally doesn't need it.
Like, I just don't want to deal with that.
I hate doing that.
- But it's also like, you
know, I feel as well like,
there's so many situations
where you're canceling
something or, you know,
you're upgrading something. Right?
And you're just like,
"All right, can you write your
phone number and address?"
And I'm like,
I'm pretty sure all my
information is on system.
Just look it up. I'll
give you my fucking name.
Just look it up.
- If it changes, I'll let you know.
I'll keep you updated.
- Like how often do you think
I'm changing my name and address?
- Like one, one thing I'm
fucking dreading when we move,
because we're all planning to
move from where we are now.
I mean, you're already
in process of moving
is just the process of
changing my address in
every bill that I've had.
And I'm just, I wake up
in a cold sweat at night
sometimes being like,
I gotta do that. I gotta do that.
- I have been suffering
for the past month on that
and it shouldn't be a suffering thing.
- It just sucks because I feel like
your life just comes to a
halt for a month because
they've designed systems that make it so.
- Yeah. And it's got nothing
to do with like, you know,
people who don't understand the language,
having a hard time, no.
Even if you're fully Japanese,
it's still hard as shit to do.
And it shouldn't be that hard to do.
- Like you get pretty good
customer service in most aspects
of, of Japanese life I think.
But for some reason with
personal information companies,
I feel like it comes to
a halt and it doesn't,
it doesn't improve at all.
The customer service
isn't any better for it.
I think that's why I think
Japan has one of the lowest
productivities out of,
of first world countries.
- I'm not surprised.
- Because they work the most.
- We would have flying cars by now.
- They work more hours
than any other country
and have less to show for
it. You know what I mean?
Like, you know, I think
in some European countries
they're considering a
four day workweek even,
and you know I was just like, fantastic.
- You bring that up to
government officials in Japan
they're like.
"How does, how does that country run?"
"How is that not a third world country?"
"How's their economy not
crumbling to the ground?"
- Again. It's just
like, how do you fix it?
When everything in society has
been made to be long-winded,
bloated and slow? Like, what do you do?
Like how do you fix that?
'Cause it's like a whole
cultural thing at that point.
- Well this is a country where,
a lot of schools are
still six days a week.
It's ridiculous. Let alone
four day workweek what?
- Yeah I mean,
it took like a fucking
global pandemic, right?
For the country to
embrace working from home
and online meetings. Right?
It's like.
- They were throwing out
like the buzzword of like
home workstation or whatever
the fuck it was like,
it was a new thing that was
just invented. It's like,
we've come up with this
revolutionary thing.
Get this, you can work from home.
And Japanese people
are like, "Impossible."
That that is.
- Telework.
- Telework that's it.
- They call it telework.
- I think also, I think they're now
slowly starting to phase
out the hanko because of it.
They're finally putting in like,
the government they're
bringing it up. And trying.
- Have we ever explained
hankos? I don't think we have.
- Hanko are basically, is
like the, it's like a stamp
essentially that has your
surname on it or, you know,
company name or whatever.
Basically it's the Japanese
equivalent of a signature.
But incredibly tedious.
- It's incredibly tedious because
that means you have to
carry your hanko everywhere.
- Yeah.
- Whenever you're like, if you forget.
- I've had moments where I'm like,
I have everything except the hanko
and they just don't accept it.
And I'm just like, this is a
stamp I bought at Don Quijote.
for like 200 yen.
Don Quijote is like the dollar shop here.
You can, you can just
get it at a dollar shop.
- Imagine your name is Connor, right?
And then, you know, you can, you know,
you can go those gift shops
and they have like the license plates,
like Connor. It's like that.
Like imagine you just go to the store,
you find your name on the license plate
and then you bring it and go look,
it's my name. It's my
name, take a picture.
- The thing is, is like, I,
I wrote up a thing as to why
Japan still uses the hanko
and not signatures and
the most accepted like,
excuse, I guess,
I'm just going to call
it an excuse as they,
as why they don't use
signatures, they were like,
"Well, anyone can copy a signature."
Anyone can go to Don
Quijote and buy a $2 stamp.
What are you on?
- Yeah. It's so dumb.
Yeah. I mean, if you have a popular name.
- Yeah.
- What happens if you have
a popular name, right?
- What is it? What is it?
What's the one that you see,
Tanaka? Is that the one?
- Yeah Tanaka or like
Sato or like any of like
the common ones.
- Everyone probably,
every Sato probably has
the same fucking Don Quijote stamp.
I'm like, this is bullshit.
Like signature is way harder
to copy than buying a stamp.
- Did you hear about the
fucking Josh battle royale
that happened recently?
- [Connor] Yeah yeah.
- [Joey] What?
- [Garnt] Did you hear about this?
- [Joey] No.
- So like, I think like a year ago,
some guy in like some state or something,
he looked up every, he was, his name was,
- Josh Swain. Josh Swain.
- Josh Wayne?
- Josh Swain.
He looked up like every Josh on Facebook
in his area and added
them to a group right?
And he just sends a message,
"Guys. You know why we're here."
- We're going to battle
for name Josh Swain.
- [Garnt] There are already Joshes here.
We are going to have a
battle royale and whoever,
whoever emerges victorious
can keep the name Josh.
- So that's how it works with hankos.
- There's literally a movie.
- I feel like they have to
do that with hankos right?
- There's literally
a fucking battle royale movie in Japan
where it's that exact same concept.
- Is it really?
- Yeah yeah. It's called, it's called
"Riaru Onigokko", "Real Tag"
where basically it's,
it's like a survival horror movie.
It's actually a really
good movie and book,
but basically in the it's
set in like the future
where the king of Japan, his name is Sato,
which is the most common surname in Japan.
And he's like,
"I want to be the only Sato."
So what he does is
every night at midnight,
he's like all of the Satos in the country
have to come out.
- He picks legend game.
- Yeah. Literally.
And they're like, and they're like.
"To all Satos of Japan.
There are too many of you.
"So we're going to get
rid of some of you."
And it's like literally
a survival horror movie
where all the Satos are
like running for their life,
not to get fucking eliminated.
- That sounds epic. I want to watch this.
- It's a great fucking movie. Yeah.
- It sounds like an anime.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it really does.
No, it's a great movie, but
it's literally like that.
- I'm just trying to think.
Is there anything in like
UK or Australia that is like
unnecessarily like slow?
I feel like we just kind of get rid of it.
- Internet.
- I mean, we've already
complained about that.
- I feel like as in like
the systems that we have.
I don't really think there's
anything that's like,
everything's been like easy to do.
- Like I didn't really have
experience living on my own
in Australia. So I can't
really say much about.
- I mean in the UK everything
that could be done online
is done online. You know, I,
I cannot even,
I don't even think I ever
went anywhere in person
for anything like government.
Like it could all be done
by phone or by online.
Water bill, internet, phone,
government documents like local tax.
Like all of it was done online.
- I think the only thing
really is like, you know,
going to get like a driver's license fixed
or something right?
Like you probably have
to go in person for that.
- Even then in the UK you can,
you can get it mailed to you.
- When I renewed my driver's license,
I literally just sent, sent
them the license in the mail,
uploaded a scan of my picture
and then they just renewed it for me.
- Okay. You can't do that in Australia.
- We've really been like,
the UK has gotten really
good at making things,
- It's efficient. I guess I
just took that for granted.
Right?
- You sure did Garnt. You sure did.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- You're like, "Everywhere's like this".
- Like I'm, I'm like, I thank God
that we're signed with GeeXPlus
and they handle our tax.
- Yeah.
'Cause like,
- Oh God. I can only imagine doing.
I've heard horror stories.
- I mean, I did my tax
before joining GeeXPlus
and it was the fucking worst.
If you are a freelancer in Japan,
good luck doing tax.
- I've heard. I've heard that
freelance tax forms in Japan
are the worst thing,
- It is godawful.
- Doing tax in the UK is bad enough.
And I'm just like, if, if that was bad,
how was it in fucking Japan?
- God awful. I hate it. I regret it.
- I thought it was bad in the UK,
but not now I look back at
how doing taxes in the UK,
like everything can be
done online. From home.
- Yeah everything can
be done online at home.
- It's pretty good. There's
an app you know, like.
- In Japan you have to take a
fucking bag full of receipts
to like the town ward and like scan.
- [Connor] No.
- Yeah, go through all of them
and like fill it in yourself.
- [Connor] Oh my.
- It is the worst.
That's why,
that's why there's no freelancers in Japan
because they're like,
"Fuck that. I don't want
to deal with that shit.
"I'll join a company."
- That's so sad.
- That's the worst.
- I will say though,
that it was pretty cool
the first time I discovered
the hanko and it, you know,
- It's cool for 10 seconds
until it becomes a burden.
- It's, it's cool for like the first week
you're living here in
here when you're like,
"Ooh, I'm stamping my"
- "I'm part of Japan now.
"I'm part of the culture here guys".
- "Let me, let me put my signature per."
- "Look at my clan. It's
the Maneetapho clan."
'Cause that's what it feels like. Right?
When you're fucking stamping
your second name down,
you're like,
- Bro this is like a
really like traditional,
like kind of swirly like
feudal Japan style stamp. It looks dope.
- It looks dope. I could,
I could see why they haven't
like gotten rid of it.
'Cause it feels like I feel cultured
as I'm stamping my fucking name down.
You know, you know when you see like
an old, in old films where you know,
they're writing a letter
and they fucking stamp down
the wax.
- The wax.
- That's what it feels like every time I,
every time I stamp down my hanko.
But then it gets to a point where
you live here for a year
and you're just like,
"Fuck's sake.
"Can we not just go back to signatures?"
- Just give me a pen.
- You know, you stamp it.
And they're like,
"No, it's not good enough.
"You haven't stamped it good enough."
- I'm like, what do you
mean? I can read it.
- Oh, it's slightly crooked.
Can you fill it in again, please?
- If it's slightly crooked,
and if there's slightly
not enough ink on it,
they just won't accept it.
- Yeah well so I remember, I filled out
like this three page document
and I made one mistake and
I did the line through it.
And the guy at the driving
lesson place is like,
"You gotta redo it all."
I'm like, why?
"You made a mistake.
You got to redo it all."
- I'm like you can't
cross things out here.
- I'm like, I crossed it
out right there. It's,
- A hundred percent
accuracy only in Japan.
- I'm like, what do you, what do you mean?
You can clearly,
- There is no any percentage in Japan
only a hundred percent wrong.
- I'm like you can clearly make out
that there is absolutely no problem here.
You know that I don't mean
the thing that I crossed out
and you know the thing,
what I meant to put.
Why are you going to make me fill out
this three page document again?
Because I made one mistake.
It's like, it's like,
everything is a fucking like trapeze act
where if you fuck up, you've
got to redo your whole life.
Born. Do life again. Reset life.
- Jesus.
- Yeah only perfection here.
- I'm surprised that they you know,
when you fill out a
document wrong they're like,
"Nope, no license for
you. Come back next day.
"Gotta redo it again."
- Basically, if you want to live in Japan,
I hope you like filling
out forms because you are,
- Correctly.
- Correctly because you are
- No mistakes.
- Expect perfection in every way.
- Moving here is kind of like
Form Simulator 2021 honestly.
- So Papers, Please but every day.
(hosts laughing)
It's exhausting, man.
- Yeah. That's,
that's kind of why like I'm dreading
these next few months when we
move studios and move houses.
- I'm going to be in a
foul mood in like October
when I have to move,
I'm just gonna not want to talk to anyone.
Like fuck you.
Yeah if we're complaining now about this,
when we actually start moving, my God,
our podcast show will be
so much more depressing.
- 'Cause I know I'm going
to lose at least a week
just from this alone. So, sorry.
Sorry if you don't get any
videos for like that month.
- My fucking video schedules is like
the slowest it's ever been.
- Because of this shit.
It's, it's, it shouldn't
shouldn't be like that.
It's ridiculous.
- How do,
how do normal people
who work nine to five?
Oh, sorry. I mean, sorry.
Nine to 12 in Japan.
How do they have time to do this stuff?
I don't understand because
people don't stop working here
and stuff closes on weekends here.
So what do they do? I don't understand.
- They take paid leave.
- [Meilyne] They take a week off.
- They take a week off, are you serious?
- They take a week off to move.
Don't they only have by law
a week of paid holiday anyway?
- [Meilyne] No, no, no.
They get like 20 days.
- 20 whole days in a year.
- So you lose what, like five.
You lose a quarter of your paid holiday
if you want to move here in Japan.
- Japan, the country
where moving is a luxury,
- If you want to do anything in Japan,
you got to take a day off
to call them up and do it.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- It's ridiculous.
Oh, you know you can't,
you want to change your phone provider.
You've got to take a day
off work. How weird is that?
What the fuck? It's weird.
- The fact that you can't just do it
like during a lunch break is ridiculous.
- It's tragic. It's tragic.
It really is tragic.
- So as someone who
has moved before, Joey,
what is the moving experience
like here in Japan?
- Hell.
In one word.
- 'Cause you already moved
once here in Japan right?
- I've moved twice now.
- Oh, you've moved twice.
- Yeah so the place I'm about to move to
will be my fourth place.
- Oh shit. Okay.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- You moved twice, but
you've had four places?
- Well, yeah.
- How does that work?
- Well, I mean, I mean,
I moved in here and then I
moved two separate times.
- Oh okay.
- Sorry sorry. Yeah.
- I was like, wait those
numbers don't add up.
- Two plus two equals four.
- Well, the first time I moved,
when I moved from Australia to Japan,
it was a lot easier for
me because I had help.
I had help from my, like my auntie.
So she did all the paperwork for me.
'Cause I didn't know fucking how to do it.
But then she was like, all right,
well now you know how to do it.
I'm like, What? Do I?
Do I?
- It's like when someone
builds a PC for you.
Like great. You can do it on your own now.
- Like you've passed the tutorial stage.
- But I hope you were paying attention.
I'm like, thanks.
- Expert mode begin.
- It's not even like a,
"Would you like to listen
to that again?" option.
It's just like, I hope you were listening.
Yeah. So the first time
when I moved here was fine.
But then from the second time on
when I moved to my own place.
Yeah, it was hell and
it's and it's still hell,
This is the third time I'm doing it now.
And it's not easier at all.
Like the only thing
that makes it easier now
is that you know exactly the
list of things you need to do.
But the list of don't,
but the process of
going through that list.
- The time is not any more efficient.
It is just as time consuming
and fucking ridiculous.
- It's why no one moves right?
No one wants to improve that
life because they're like,
Well, I do want to improve my life.
- But that's what I'm saying right?
- You know, I've got
asbestos. I've got mold,
but you know, frankly,
putting up that paperwork,
- Well that's what I'm saying.
It's not an understatement to say that or
not an overreaction to say that
moving in Japan is a luxury
and it shouldn't be a luxury.
It's fucking ridiculous.
- That's, that's why they're
able to charge the same amount
when you have to renew
your contract right?
- Yeah.
- Which is why I don't know
where you're explaining this,
but the reason we're all moving is because
when your contract ends for
like your rental period,
normally you'd think it
can just easily roll over
and stuff like that
- That's how it does in the UK.
That's that's how it
did in Thailand for me.
- Most countries yeah.
- That's how I did in most countries.
Nope. You've got to go
through the same process again
and pay the same fees.
- So you gotta pay two
months of rent for free.
For no reason. Just, because they want it.
It's like, No fuck you.
I'm not giving you two
months of money for free.
For what? For this shitty
apartment? Fuck off.
- Yeah. It's ridiculous.
- Yeah. I hate it.
- Did you use like a moving company
the first time you moved?
- Yeah I got a moving
company, but I mean the,
the moving company we're using for now,
the new place is like
has like a service where like
they'll come in and like pack it for you.
Like wheeling off the moving company
is probably the easiest thing
to sort out when moving.
It's everything else that's
a pain. Like the inter,
the internet is the fucking worst.
- Oh I can imagine.
- Like setting up internet
for a new place is, ugh.
- That's hard in the UK as well.
That's like the hardest one
because they're just like,
they're just like,
"Oh yeah. So are you okay with
"going four months without
internet in your new place?"
It's like,
No. No I'm fucking not.
- Yeah but at least like
with our current place,
like they'll give us like a,
like a kind of portable or not portable,
but like a rental WiFi kind of thing.
So you're not like
completely out of internet.
- [Connor] Still sucks though.
- Yeah it still sucks that
I have to wait for like
the full price to like kick in. But yeah.
Yeah. I mean, yeah.
The moving company is
weirdly the smoothest thing.
- Sick.
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
- I remember in the UK,
when I moved all my stuff
to my parents' house,
I, again, I was trying to
do it as cheap as possible.
And there was like a
service that had like vans,
but for Uber.
It's called like AnyVan
or something in the UK.
Pay the guy.
Guess how much it cost to go basically
from London to North Wales,
like that's like basically half the UK.
How much do you think that costs
to hire that van?
- Like, like one van?
- Just one guy in a van just driving.
- Normally I'd think maybe like, I dunno,
300 pounds maybe?
- It was 120 pounds. I think I paid.
- That sounds sus as fuck.
- And I was so fucking
scared the whole time
when this put my, because
this guy was just like,
"All right, what are we doing?
"Where are we putting the boxes?"
What are we doing, it
was just like some guy,
like, again, again, like
Uber for vans just chilling.
He was really nice. And my mom was like,
"Yeah, he was really nice."
when he got there.
I was like, sick.
It was so cheap. And I was like,
this guy can't be getting
much so I gave him a fat tip.
'Cause apparently he was really nice
and was really helpful to my mom.
- That sounds scary though. Isn't it?
That just calls for some dude
who has all your stuff
in his van and then just
drives off into the middle of nowhere.
- There was just, there was
a GPS tracker on his car.
But again, he could just take,
- Oh you went with him?
- No.
- Oh, okay.
- That's even more scary.
- Just give them all my,
all my valuable stuff.
Like see you later.
- Jesus Christ.
- So your laptop, your PC, everything.
- Yeah everything, everything.
- Geez. That's,
- That's scary. Yeah.
- And somehow we fit it
all in a van and everything
and yeah, somehow it was fine.
The service was great, paid.
It was pretty much cheap as fuck.
- [Joey] Yeah Jesus.
- I'm thinking I'm like,
the fuel must've been
like half of that cost.
Like this man cannot be
getting any money from this.
That's why I was like, fat tip.
- He might be living
just strictly off tips.
- Yeah. I don't know.
Fuck, I feel bad. But.
- Yeah I don't know 'cause
like tipping culture,
I don't know.
Tipping culture is different
everywhere in the world.
And in the UK, it's you guys
are kind of in the middle I
guess, of tipping culture.
Japan is nonexistent,
which, you know, there are,
there are times when I wish
that I could tip people in Japan.
'Cause I get some of the
best customer service here
I've ever had worldwide.
And I can't tip people here
- It's because it's the whole
philosophy of, you know,
the best customer service is expected.
- Wait what was the
tangent that we were on
before I started talking about my van?
- We were talking about
your moving company right?
- Moving company.
- I basically just said
the moving company was
- Doing it. Oh yeah. Sure easy.
- Because when I moved in the UK
from London back to Brighton
like just use Gumtree
and I, I feel like with the UK,
I, I don't know anyone
who's actually moved,
used the moving company.
Everyone's just knowing a mate, whoever.
- Everyone has mates to do it.
- At least one friend
has like a giant van.
- I mean that's because putting our age.
But I think when the people
who use moving companies
are like families. Just
absurd amounts of stuff.
- That makes sense.
- At my age, I, I,
when I moved out I recycled or threw away
probably about 70% of my belongings.
'Cause I'm like, I
don't need this anymore.
Like, 'cause I was like,
oh, well, you know, I like,
I put everything on for free on Gumtree.
All my stuff was like, come get it.
Who wants my wardrobe?
Who wants my fucking?
- Well I did with like,
without car movers as well,
there's like a Japanese
site that we can just
throw like couches and beds for free.
And people just come pick it up.
- People will go on like Craigslist,
like fucking give things,
- Because like throwing out
trash here costs fucking money
and like an absurd amount
of money to throw out.
Where I'm just like, why
would anyone do that?
- Just give it to someone.
- True, true. Shit, I
just remembered banks.
Sorry. Sorry to shit on banks again.
You can't, I remember
I was in, I was out in Shibuya
and I was out till like 2:00 AM
and I was like, all right,
well I want to go home now.
So I'll go get a taxi.
And I was like, great,
well, I've got no money.
So I'm just gonna quickly go
and get some money from the ATM.
It turns out that after working hours,
you just can't withdraw
money. So you know, fuck me,
I was stranded in the middle of nowhere.
I can't get money.
I have to wait until what 8:00
AM until the banks open up.
For some reasons the ATMs
stop fucking working.
- I've never, I don't
think I've ever had to.
- I don't think I've ever had
to take money out like that.
- No, sometimes I have a good night.
You know, I spend more than I intended to.
I got no more cash left.
No biggie. I'll get some
from the ATM. No. Fuck me.
Fuck me. And even if it
is during working hours,
I got to pay anyway, what am I paying for?
It's an ATM.
There's no one there,
there's no one in the machine
giving you money is there?
Is there just a small man
sleeping in the machine
who's awake during these
hours? Why is it this much?
- Yeah. Like, like there are
some ATMs like to, to explain.
There are some ATMs in
the UK that do charge
to take money out.
But they are like, they're like the like
no branded ATMs
- Sketch as fuck ones.
- At some, at some
sketchy like corner shops,
- Those are the ones where like,
there's probably a man inside.
Just taking your money.
- Those are the ones where it's fucking
2:00 AM or something.
You just need some fucking money out
to go to the club or something.
And you're like, sure.
I'll pay five pounds to take out my
20 pound entry fee to this club, whatever.
I'm drunk enough to do it.
Now, imagine now, imagine that.
But for every transaction you do
and that's, that's taking
out money here in Japan.
You have to take out a lot of money.
- Yeah. They charge like five
bucks each time or something.
- Yeah they charge like five bucks every,
- I want to access my fucking,
- Unless you go to that
bank's branded ATM.
- But even then sometimes
though, they charge you.
- Yeah. Because yeah,
because you have a limit
as to how many times you can
take money out per month.
- But that depends. If, if you,
for some reason you're a rich motherfucker
and you have X amount of
money in your bank, it's free.
They're like, no, no, no. it's on us.
You have a lot of money with us.
We ain't going to charge you.
- Punish the poor. Feed the rich.
- Why? Why are you taxing
the fucking poor people?
What the fuck? That's
just like what's wrong.
It's like everything in this system
is designed to make you hate them.
- Damn you capitalism.
- Like I, what I was, when I,
when I wanted to get the
taxi home, I was like,
I'm so goddamn lucky that
I have a foreign card
that I just carry on me at emergencies.
'Cause I'm like, you never know.
- Yeah. For my, my
foreign, my British card
is just like my getaway,
get out of jail free card.
It's like 100% more reliable
than using the card in the
country it was made from,
like how does that work?
- My British bank card
works at every single ATM,
any time of the day, whenever.
They don't charge me.
They just charge me the exchange
rate cost, which I accept,
you know, cause I'm changing the money.
Whatever. They got to do
that. But you know, I don't,
I genuinely don't know how I
would've got home that night
if I, if I didn't have my British card.
What do Japanese people do in this?
Do they just go to the
fucking manga cafes don't they?
- Well, no, because then
you'd have to pay for the manga cafe.
- Oh shit yeah. That's true.
- They literally sleep
outside the station.
- Homeless Simulator for like six hours.
- I mean, you've probably seen it before.
They just literally sleep
outside of the station.
- Oh is that like the
Shibuya Meltdown shit?
- Shibuya Meltdown is something else.
But like sometimes I've seen, you know,
walking past the station or whatever
there's like couples and
like, you know, businessmen
just sleeping outside
of the station, waking,
waiting for it to wake up.
- Yeah.
- Like it's ridiculous.
- Absolute insanity that
this is what it has come to.
- Like talking about this
now. I'm like, I I'm, I'm,
I'm really starting to
sweat this year right?
Because, because of the world's situation,
haven't been able to track
to travel back to the UK.
And I look at the expiry day
on my card and it's like,
it's like creeping up. Right?
'Cause it was, it was like,
'cause before I moved up.
- It's like the "Death Note" counter.
- They send you an automatic one though.
At least my bank does.
- Yeah it sends me to my UK address,
which no one is living in right now.
'Cause my parents are in fucking Thailand
and I'm here in Japan.
So my, my I'm not going to
say what the exact date,
- My exact address.
- It is, it is in 2021, my
expiry date for my British card.
I'm just like,
- Wait when does mine expire?
- I'm, I'm starting to
sweat 'cause I'm just like,
Shit man.
If I can't travel back to
the UK to get my new cards
then I'm kind of just like
resting on my Japanese cards
to work now.
- Mine's 2023. We good. We
gucci. We gucci. Fuck you Garnt.
- Yeah. It's scary. Fucking hell.
- Yeah. I mean that was a,
that was a nice little rant.
- Thanks a hell here.
Sorry. I'm sure most people
have absolutely no care in the world
about Japanese banks, but now you know
a lot more about them
about how shit they are.
- Well there's probably a lot of audiences
of Trash Taste who are like,
one day I want to live in
Japan and live that weeb dream.
Just be prepared.
- I think we've done a good
job at least, you know,
bigging up the stuff
that is worth, you know,
giving praise to.
And we're brutally honest
about the shit parts.
- Honestly, like all things
considered Japan is like,
I don't know if it's the best,
but it's definitely like either
comparing the UK to Japan,
it's been a fucking amazing place to live.
And I don't know if
I'd put it as the best,
but it's definitely,
- Well the pluses definitely
outweigh the minuses.
- I think I enjoy living here
more than the UK. More so.
- I mean I'm definitely have enjoyed
my previous year and a half
more than I have in the UK.
We'll see how I am five years
down the line, you know?
But right now I can, I'm definitely
- I'm approaching my fifth year.
- I'm definitely gonna
be here for at least
two, three more years I think.
- Yeah.
- Definitely. Definitely.
Because I fucking love it
here. It's so much fun.
It's an amazing country.
- So expect Trash Taste
for at least another two or three years.
- Just don't, just don't
tell me I have to move house
or fucking change my internet
or change my phone because I
am going to get a headache.
- Just tell me ahead of
time when that happens
'cause I'll just fucking wooo,
get out of there before I'm
like trying to like this,
this rant is me like mentally
preparing for like the, the,
the month in like the month
and this year that I'm going to
have to dedicate to moving.
- Yeah. I mean paying taxes
was way more, like much,
much more enjoyable than,
than doing any of the
forms I had to do in Japan.
It's weird. But anyway,
you know who doesn't
charge us to use ATMs,
our wonderful patreons.
- Oh my God, look at them.
- But look at this guy here on screen.
- They live rent free in our heads.
- I would've charged them to
get their money outta here.
- I bet they have a good banking system.
That's why they're supporting us.
(hosts laughing)
- Touche.
- But I bet this guy could
get his bank statement online.
- I bet they can play or pay
all their bills online right?
- Of course they can.
Hey, if you'd like to
support the show man.
- That's what they're doing right now.
- Yeah, make sure to go to
www.patron.com/trashtaste.
- [Connor] I just look forward to the day
where I don't have to pay
my bills by carrier pigeon.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- [Connor] Can't wait for it.
But thank you so much for watching
this episode of Trash
Taste. Hope you enjoyed it.
And don't forget to
listen to us on Spotify,
go to the Reddit and check out the memes.
- Oh my God. You said it.
- Yeah that's the thing.
- Holy shit.
- I did it for once. Sorry Joey.
- I got to do that next time.
- Damn, my job is obsolete now
- You're obsolete now Joey.
Thank you so much for watching
this episode of Trash Taste. See ya.
- Bye!
(lively music)